good morning
McCauley
uh
finance committee to order
and I have to read a script
as chair of the house finance committee
I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
19 pandemic and in accordance with the
governors
Nancy his Mike is off he's not coming
through
yeah I see that
getting a bit of a feedback from them
[Music]
all right should we start
yes sir
I think you're all set
hey good morning
call me house finance committee meeting
to order
and this chair of the house finance
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12
to the executive order
2020-04 as extended this public body is
authorized to meet electronically
here in the room and the rest are
electronic please note that there is no
physical location to observe and then
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with the emergency order I'm
confirming that we uh a providing public
asset access to the meeting by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electronic means we elect
we're utilizing Zoom video webinar for
this remote meeting while members of the
committee and the staff are state
agencies with agenda items have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously watch and or listen to
the meeting on Zoom or photo following
the directions and links provided by the
house calendar at HTTP meeting colon
backslash backslash gen Court
g-e-n-c-o-u-r-t dot s-t-a-t-e dot NH dot
us backslash house
c-a-l-j-o-u-r-n-s slash calendars
c-a-l-e-n-d-a-r-s slash 2021 slash
uppercase Hotel Charlie oh HC
uh space H dot PDF
writing public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting telephonically
instructions have been provided in the
house calendar and C providing a
mechanism for the public to alert the
public body during the meeting if there
are problems with access if anybody has
a problem please email
leg.state.nh.us adjourning the meeting
of the public is a if the if the public
is unable to access the meeting
if the in the event the public is unable
to access the media meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to no law many of the members are
here present in our meeting room we'll
ask for the Roll Call
thank you Mr chairman uh can you hear me
are you on you got to push pressure
foreign
[Music]
okay can you hear me now there we go all
right
we're gonna get some feedback
representative Ober
I'm in my home in Hudson and I have cats
and a husband wondering about
again
[Music]
president suburbish
virgin Petri is here in 210 to 11.
representative Emrick I'm in my home
office alone in Hampton
here in 210 to 11.
Senate
my whole office alone
thank you thank you representative
Griffin
representative Doucette for being
present
representative
representative Edwards I'm president in
the uh
representative Lynn present in the
meeting room
representative
no
I can barely hear that
okay
[Music]
representative Weiler would you like to
foreign
ER would you like to recess this meeting
for five minutes
give me a thumbs up
okay that's what we will do we're gonna
go ahead sir
all right we will now begin discussion
all right I understand we haven't
finished the roll call so we'll continue
with the roll call till we get that
finished
I think we have a replica I think we
have a replacement as uh representative
Porter are you replacing representative
bucco
19 pandemic and in accordance with the
oh that's the uh recordings
all right I don't I don't know where
representative Buco is expected to be on
remote As is representative nordgren
who's going to expect it to be late so
we'll go on with the rest and see if
representative hatch I've seen here very
good
representative Rogers
I'm here in my apartment in Concord
um Wayne is here but my dog and I
representative is
he is here in the room present thank you
representative Porter for Murray I'm
here in my home in Hillsboro my
husband's in the house but not in the
room
very good representative Wilder
president in in the committee room
chairman there are 20
people present foreign
yes I did I believe yeah yeah
okay we have in the first part of our
our
agenda is 10 bills nine of which were uh
on retained status
within their division
um
so the first the first group is from
division one
um
representative Oliver wishes to read
them one by one and describe what they
are and why they were retained what
chairman
the division unanimously retained all of
these and the reason was they all had
money and should either be in budget
because we were doing budget
deliberations we should be retained to
work on later in actual fact two of the
bills were put into the budget we have
HB 63 relative to the reversal of
forgiveness for emergency order
violations
hb91 relative to death benefits of First
Responders who died from suicide
established in the office of the right
to no Ombudsman in making an approach
appropriation thereof between 498
relative to the payment of bail
Commissioners HP 536 relative to the
death benefits for Public Works
employees killed in the line of duty and
relative to workers compensation offsets
for certain retirement system benefits
and finally HB 591 relative to liquor
license fees the unit as I said the
division unanimously voted to retain all
uh yes sir
we had two bills HB 254 and HB 600 we
retained unanimously HB 254 this is a
bill relative to the placement of miners
in Secure settings we rolled the
language of 254 into hb2 and we retain
this one so that we could have further
discussions on the
sununu Center
that's on retained the other one we want
to pass so I won't discuss that now
[Music]
hello
seconds the motion is to retain the nine
bills that just detail we'll ask the
clerk to call the roll on your vote to
retain if you're in favor of retaining
you'll say yes if you're opposed you'll
say no clerk will call the roll Mr
chairman
someone had a question yes chairman I do
I'm at home I can hear nothing you just
said there's a roll call on something I
have no idea what
I've not been able to hear anybody speak
since you asked me to read the names of
the bills we've retained
okay I think I saw your the yellow thing
around your thing I wonder if you had
your mic on and that was blocking the
voices chairman I don't have Michael and
I didn't I had to turn it on to talk to
you
okay what what we just did and I think
you have the uh the agenda before you
after you read the bills from division
one representative lumberger read the
two bills from Vision tune and uh then
representative Edwards read one bill
from division three the other one we're
going to get to now so the motion was to
retain those nine bills did can you hear
me now
yes Mr chairman thank you I think
perhaps representative amberger and
Edwards either did not have their mics
on or the mics weren't pulled close to
them we learned that when we were
working in 202 you have to have the mic
pretty close thank you yeah I think it's
about two inches
and for the last roll call I see now we
have representative Buco on thank you
welcome
thank you
and the clerk will call a roll on the
motion
to retain nine bills which have been
I don't think she's hearing you I can't
hear you she's muted
no it was muted try pressing the blue
representative mum Burger representative
uh representative chirkoff for Danielson
representative votes yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick representative
memory coach yes representative yes
representative Griffin
yes
representative Edwards
uh yes
representative Doucette for being yes
representative Lynn yes
there was in a walner yes
Virginia buco
representative leishman yeah
representative hatch yes
representative Rogers
um I'm voting yes but I'm supposed to
have my camera on but it says the host
will not let me turn my camera on so
oops
I think because we had problems that the
host ended up muting that a lot of mics
and cameras I see most of the uh cameras
are muted at this point okay thank you
representative walls
I vote Yes but like representing of
Rogers my camera hasn't been working it
will not work you know we have this rule
that says you have to be you have to be
able to save your picture
all right Nancy can can you bring up the
pictures as he calls a roll because we
have to be able to see that that's the
person I see uh representative walls now
representative walls is on
okay
representative Heath Heath votes yes
representative Porter for Murray
representative Porter votes yes
representative Wilder
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 20 to 20
votes an affirmative
and the motion is adopted to retain the
nine bills we'll now look at House Bill
600 and I'll call on representative
Edwards to explain the bill and also the
amendment
uh should I first introduce it and then
we discuss it yes you should uh Mr
chairman I'd like to make a motion that
we consider and approve an OTP with
Amendment for HP 600-5n
second okay and representative Earth
seconds
uh
directs the commissioner to change the
way it gets billed so that it comes
across as a diagnostic test and making
the change from a supply to a test it
will allow insurance companies to
reimburse for the service you must will
create a a must stream of income for the
Departments and breathing centers
oh man changes the effective date from
the original bull which was 60 days the
amendment changes it to 120 days 120
days was requested by the department so
they had an adequate amount of time to
do the it changes that would be required
to support the
new rule
thank you I guess technically we have to
so if you would move the amendment then
I'm looking for the amendment number
representative if you would move the
amendment if you've got it handy
I believe
we amend the bill with amendment number
I'll second
motion a second to adopt the amendment
the clerk will call a roll on adopting
the amendment
09899h on House Bill 600.
[Music]
if you're in favor you'll say yes if you
opposed you'll say no clerk will call
representative Ober yes
representative umberger
yes
representative
uh yes
representative yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Earth yes
representative Edwards yes
representative for being yes
representative Lynn yes
representative walner
representative norburn
representative buco
yes
representative Leachman
[Music]
representative hatch yes
representative Rogers yes
representative Walsh yes
representative Heath Heath votes yes
representative Porter for Murray yes
representative Wilder
yes
Mr chairman there are 20 votes the
affirmative
okay we have adopted the amendment
and now representative Edwards moves the
house bill 600 ought to pass as amended
with a second from representative erf
any further discussion
seeing none the clerical called a role
on the motion ought to pass as amended
on House Bill 600.
representative Ober yes
representative umberger
yes
representative representative
representative yes representative Petrie
votes yes representative Emrick yes
representative yes representative
Griffin
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Doucet yes
representative Lynn yes
representative walner
representative
representative Leachman yeah
representative hatch yes
representative Rogers
yes
representative walls yeah
representative Heath Heath vote Yes
representative Porter yes
representative Wilder yes
Mr chairman the vote is 20. yays no
names
all right we have adopted House Bill 600
ought to pass as amended thank you
all right
[Music]
all right our discussion on HBO one will
begin at 10 o'clock as scheduled so
we'll take a break until then and hope
[Music]
um
and stop your video and we will pause
foreign
representative Weiler
we're not hearing you right now so hang
all right is it working now
yes we can hear you now sir
thank you all right
committee's call back from Recess a 10
o'clock meeting
we'll now begin our discussions of hb1
this is the budget Bill the appropriates
the funds to run the state government
for the two fiscal years beginning on
July 1st 2021 through June 30
2023 these are fiscal years 2022 through
2023. the New Hampshire Constitution
requires that all spending bills
originate in the House of
Representatives the steps in this budget
began last fall with the agency
submitting their proposals these were
reviewed by administrative Services then
the governor's office it's required that
the governor's proposal come to the
house by February 15th and about that
same time the house committee on ways
and means the committee with the
expertise on tax policy and revenues
gives an estimate on projected revenues
for those two fiscal years this sets the
target for spending that we must not
exceed the legislative process requires
that our actions result in legislation
thus the budget must be a bill that
becomes law it is traditionally hb1 and
the enabling legislation that sets the
tax policy in any rural organization
required is hb2 as the finance chair I
sponsor both hb1 and hb2 and the three
division chairs in our committees are
co-sponsors we rely on the accountants
and legislative budget assistant office
and the lawyers in the office of
legislative services to put these bills
in the proper format we only have about
five weeks to review and balance the
budget so we divide the task into
functional areas that our permanent
subcommittees which we call divisions
one two and three
we'll work on you will hear from the
chair of each division any in turn as
they explain their Pro their portion of
the budget the process from the house to
the Senate to the governor is called
appropriation
it's the time
and there's the spending Authority for
the government agencies there were over
1 500 pages of accounting limits or Aus
with the line items for each unit in hb1
hb2 had 150 pages with over 200 separate
articles many AES or accounting units we
found acceptable as filed
so we'll have a roll call after each
division makes that presentation and
perhaps they might be amendments in
there that we may have to not do another
roll call on as well so we'll wait till
each division has finished a briefing on
that portion and then we'll have the
roll call vote so we'll call upon
representative Ober chair of division
one and explain what division one
sections they they deal with and what
they've done with the budget
representative Ober
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
thank you to the LBA staff who supported
us we have a huge work effort if you
look our detailed Change Report is nine
pages long hp2 amendment is another 93
Pages we had a tremendous effort on the
part of Michael Hoffman Nancy lavinus
plus Michael Caine and Christopher Shea
but we also had support from other
committee members Ways and Means had a
number of sections that we were asked to
deal with plus added some Wars we went
along Edna helped out with some policy
sections help from Science and Tech
environment agriculture just almost too
many people to name to thank everybody
the seven members of our division worked
very diligently
last November Kenway and I attended
three days of budget hearings in
November it was apparent to us that a
number of agencies the division one
overseas would see and be facing
significant layoffs unless there were
changes in the budgets however those
changes didn't come three of our
agencies were hit
our agencies division one agencies were
hit very badly with more than 50 late
direct layoffs the normal Ploy in the
budget is to unfund vacant positions for
example there were 89 vacant positions
in Des there are hundreds of vacant
positions in HHS so normally with the
governor does is unfund those rather
this was a really hard situation for all
the division members and I think we
probably were all having nightmares of
hungry kids telling us that we laid off
their parents but together we work
through all of this so before we turn to
the
direct Change Report let me give you a
few highlights
the part of their mid-services is a
central Service Agency they do payroll
they do all kinds of things throughout
state government maintenance of
buildings they're responsible contract
bidding they're responsible they have a
unit that does all of the insurances for
all of the employees they are absolutely
critical to every agency
and you'll see that the division
utilized savings from Errata and
insurance reallocation to restore 20
positions in this agency
we move the Appropriations to pay for
the sheriff's transport and security
prisoners out of the budget of Das where
I don't believe it ever belonged and
into the judicial branch which is
allowed by state law this also eased
some of the problems that represent
hatch and representatives reported from
the North country and the North Country
budget so we listen carefully to where
every agency impacted everybody in our
state
we deleted 500 000 in premature budget
dollars for a law enforcement commission
that has not yet been recommended but
was actually budgeted at 517 thousand
dollars in Das we allocated the cost of
cyber security which impacts every state
agency
through doit which it should have been
five years ago
in doit we've provided an appropriation
to restore for shared and funded
positions for some reason their budget
cut
half of the staff that answers the phone
at the help desk so if you have a
computer problem and you call up and you
say hey I need help half of those
positions which were filled were cut we
restored that
however more than 20 patent positions
remain unfunded this is a potential
impact
across
every agency as we go forward
and I'd like to say at this point in
time I think everybody probably heard
that the governor had a few comments
during his last press release about how
the house was handling the budget and
how the Senate would handle it it's been
my experience that we have been very
collaborative with the Senate however
the Senate has stayed out of the budget
when we're over here we typically stay
out of their budget we do share
information with them they share
information with us it has been a joint
effort and I would like it to remain a
joint effort and Chuck Morse Gary
Daniels
Bob guide all the people who have worked
on the budget before have continued to
work with us and did so now
in dra we added to auditor positions and
we did that because we would get a total
of 3.2 million dollars more in Revenue
and I thank everybody on finance knows
went to the housing Ways and Means
Revenue estimates were passed
house finance needed to cut 49 million
dollars from the governor's budget or ad
Revenue so we added some Revenue
Treasury and Corrections
all of the Educational Funding
in Corrections all of the academic
training funding in Corrections
had been cut and all the people laid off
and what we did was we changed the
general fund appropriation for the
Governor's scholarship fund to one
dollar knowing that money was coming for
in the current
budget from the feds for a covered
release and we use that money to restore
most of the training and Vocational and
academic training in Corrections that
service was of course fully funded even
though it has grown
the justice department we recognize some
general fund savings by delaying the
start of a new program
and delaying the start of two attorney
positions they did get all of their
positions funded just not the first day
in The Liquor Commission we had an
amendment
that proposes to change the liquor
enforcement to a liquor Licensing Bureau
and I'd like to thank representative
wishman for all of the work he did on
this amendment
in Corrections transitional housing was
cut for Concord and Manchester
we were able to restore that
the relatively small cost of restoring
far outweighed by the benefits that
transitional housing provides
we did restore the vocational
Educational Funding as I said
the parole board was reorganized to just
five members including the chairman
which the governor had proposed the
parole board is finally going to use
some digital technology if you've ever
watched them they have a mountain of
paper every time they meet but we're
actually going to provide some digital
technology we also had to provide
networking access so that they could use
their digital technology and we kind of
did that at the last minute and then
right before we were done within
we found out that the building they're
in is going to be sold and we had to add
funding so that they would have new
housing
our Corrections Officers remains an
issue we discussed it extensively with
the commissioner even when she hires
them they're all trying just police
officers because our pay level is so low
they get trained as a corrections
officer which means they are now
certified police officer six to 12
months down the line they're looking for
a better paying job with the local
police department that's something that
we need to take on not in this budget
but we need to think about how we're
going to retain them
we increased the funding provided to the
Small Business Development Center and
business and economic Affairs the
governor had originally budgeted at
fifty thousand dollars for the coming
year and nothing in the year after the
budget they have in their budget
currently is three hundred and fifteen
thousand dollars however we looked at
how much they had spent in the previous
year which was a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars and we restored the
funding to two hundred and twenty five
thousand in each of the two years what
we did was we reduced the amount of
money they have in travel and tourism to
do this one of the reasons we were
reducing of course is because at 49
million dollars we had to cut and
chairman Weiler would say to me
periodically in the hall I hope you're
cutting because division two isn't going
to be able to cut he's he's smiling he's
shaking his head because he knew he was
giving me nightmares
part of the planning on the office of
strategic and management has now been
put in business and economic Affairs
where it will actually do planning
functions for the first time
we had a really tough decision with
Environmental Services
we have suspended the way the water
treatment grants for the biennium
not something anybody on the division
wanted to do
but I also worked heavily with LBA and
again I can't thank them enough for the
work that they did for us
we got it
um an amendment put into hb2
that will allow the department of Des to
come to fiscal at the end of every six
months and request up to 50 percent of
the Surplus above planned expenditure
and apply it to the wastewater treatment
I talked to commissioner Bob Scott he
knew why we were doing what we were
doing giving the ways and means
estimates he said he felt like it was a
reasonable start
I frequently say and I think you guys do
too the Senate always has more money
than we have and I know this makes Chuck
Norris cringe but the reality is we
passed the budget out of here in March
and in April the business taxes come in
and frequently that is a big month for
us if they come in above plan the Senate
ends up with a little bit more money
military Affairs came in they were fully
funded they are finally going to do some
Mental Health Services as you'll see
oplc
we did the last piece of their
reorganization in hb2 which was started
last biennium but got lost when we had
the pandemic and some of the scramble at
the end with the big
bills that we did not pass
the new Department it's been something
that's been discussed for several years
it's the department of energy
and we were lucky to have
the gentlelady from Beau whose husband
attorney Harry Judd has worked in this
area a lot and so you learn a lot at
home and she's also an attorney so she
was able to provide a lot of guidance
into some of the things we did with this
everybody on the division when we looked
at the long extension said this needs to
be changed that needs to be changed you
have to work through every reference in
every RSA and it has to be changed to
the new Department
what this is going to do and the
consumer Advocate is a hundred percent
behind this as well as our own stne it
reorganizes and eliminates an ongoing
conflict with the puc the puc on one
hand has been a policy making unit and
then on the other hand
they are quasi-judicial and they rule on
things that impact the ratepayer which
is difficult I mean I can't imagine
writing a policy that impacts the great
fair having the rate payer talk to me
and say but this is hurting me and now I
have to rule against my own policy it's
Department of energy will separate that
out so the puc will remain
quasi-judicial but will no longer be
writing policy
the judicial branch came and their
budget was approved they did ask they
have an authorized amount of 45 judges
in the district court they had been
limited to 35 they asked to go to 37 we
agreed
we looked at hb2 sections we have rooms
and meals tax carry forward vet
and I can't thank again Ways and Means
enough for what they did for us Peter
leashman also worked on the organization
of the hb2 section that looks at the
Lakes Region facility and when he got
done with his work the division passed
that unanimously and we will look at
that could I ask LBA if maybe they could
bring up the our detail change at this
point and we can look at some of the
specifics in that is it possible to
share that on the screen
who's running the screen for us I can
call that up representative Ober thank
you so much
oh I think Mike Hoffman's got it oh good
you guys are just great
thank you very much so if we could go to
page one we're looking at division one
category one and you can see at the top
there aren't any changes and then if you
look in the middle of the page row 12
Department of Information Technology
we have
additional funds for hardware and
software that had to be added because
the parole board's funding for their new
digitization process had was not
accurate we also had
an impact of the DI of I.T on the
department of energy they first started
and they put all of their money
scattered among the various Aus at the
last minute they wanted to consolidate
them and we did that
you look at row 15 we had to transfer
from administrative services
and a way to pay the cost of cyber
security which Das does the contract for
gets but it extends it across to all of
the agencies
and you'll find that there's a
in our packet of hb2 amendments on page
six you will find the amendment that
does that for the shared services
position that we put back
under Department of administration
starting on line 18 if you look to the
very far column with
comments
you see consistently restores restores
restores
I talked to you earlier about positions
that have been laid off we have added
back Staffing we did this without adding
a lot of costs because we found a couple
of things number one
Das had been over budgeted for
maintenance
to the tune of over six hundred thousand
dollars
they also have been charged for all the
cyber security which was over six
hundred thousand dollars
and then remember I said we eliminated
that
law enforcement commission that had been
budgeted too early for them at five
hundred and seventeen thousand dollars
we were up to almost 1.8 million dollars
in adjustments just in Das that added no
money added no spending but allowed us
to make some changes that would benefit
the state as a whole and Mike if we
could go to the second page at the very
top
we have moved that from their budget
one of the problems with the sheriff's
reimbursements quite honestly has come
from felonies first
when we didn't have felonies first
everything went through District Court
District Court used video arraignments
in the jails the sheriffs did not
provide transportation they do not
provide security in the courthouses for
the prisoners the prisoners stayed in
the jails however with felonies first
the Superior Court no longer would use
video arraignments
the sheriff's now transported the
prisoners and they provided Security in
the courthouses all day long while the
prisoners were there in Hillsborough
County this was a nightmare because
we're the only County with two Superior
Courts we did not have two bands to
transport prisoners at the same time to
the two different
courts when we started lost all the
video arraignment we had a lot of
expense in Hillsborough County but it
has added to the cost
judicial branch can best monitor that
cost Das had no idea and since the state
law says
they will be reimbursed up to the Limit
that was budgeted that meant towards the
end of the year none of our County
budgets were getting the money they
you can see that we
had archives under the State Library
some of the sources of the general funds
had to be budgeted correctly this was
primary Errata that had to be redone
although it was a lot of keen on the
part of LBA and I thank them again for
not only getting the Amendments but
getting the key and done
you move down to graphic Services we're
looking at line 32 and line 33.
some of the people were laid off we have
set up in hp2 a fund for them so that
the money they earn will stay in that
fund and will pay for their people as it
should and will no longer go to general
fund
under the Property and Casualty
Insurance that's where you see the Das
change for the cyber security that I
mentioned earlier
the housing appeals board in Line 39 we
actually unfunded
three positions we looked at the law
that passed and they were allocated a
set amount of positions and suddenly in
this budget they had three more
positions than
allowed in the law so we unfunded them
keeping in mind we were trying to get to
the cuts that the chairman kept asking
me for so the growth was above what was
passed in state law and they were
absolutely done the next line line 40
reflects the 517 thousand dollars that
was removed from Das budget because it
was budgeted too soon you'll see when
representative umberger talks about
division two that they are working on
that as rightly so they should but we
also had it budgeted which was kind of a
shock
so that was how we got part of our Cuts
if you can turn the page Mr Hoffman and
I'm at the top of the page with
Department of Revenue Administration I
mentioned that we added two Auditors
which gained us three million dollars
at line 56 you will see that we have put
only one dollar in the governor's
scholarship fund we used all of that
money to fund Corrections vocational and
academic training and we're going to we
stood United as a Division behind those
cuts
then if you go down to line 186
we have the office of professional
licensure and certification
yeah
we have on page 29 House Bill 2 Section
64 and 65 we abolished just an
established positions as they move
positions around to match the
reorganization
page four is just summary Mr Hoffman if
we could go to page five
thank you
the judicial branch the Top Line you
will see the money to pay for the
prisoner transport and prisoner security
age 13 in our packet we have an
amendment if you're looking at your hb2
packet as well we have an amendment that
eliminates 1.5 million dollars
and what that did we talked to military
affairs
they were funded 1.5 million dollars for
mental health services and instead there
is an amendment that authorizes them and
talks to them about collaborating with
VA to participate with some of the Buddy
programs and some of the PTSD and mental
health programs are our veterans have
over there plus we were aware by that
time that although we wouldn't have the
money during our budget cycle that there
was money in the coverage relief bill
that Congress has asked to support this
so although that was that was eliminated
they agreed that they were getting money
and that they would work with the VA and
it was a good place to start they did
get their two people to work on this
line seven and eight Department of
Agriculture we basically had no change
except
on the
consent calendar last time we passed a
bill
that went to Ways and Means because it
uses dedicated funds House Bill 532 to
create an animal records database
it was requested by the chairman of Vice
chairman of environment would this be
added to the budget and moved along the
Senate has a companion bill on this over
on their side as well
Ways and Means was aware that we had it
I don't know if they retained it or not
because they got it since it was
dedicated funding
now in the Justice Department you can
see that we have delayed the start of
some of the attorney positions
we delayed the start because it does as
you can see in FY 22 and FY 23 it does
give you a significant amount of cut
when you're trying to cut 100 or 49
million dollars but it does not cut the
positions and this is a place where if
the revenues continue to go up
and the revenue plan gets better it's
easy for the Senate to say well we're
going to
move those forward because we don't need
you see on line 14 we have an amendment
that deletes an appropriation to the frm
victims Recovery Fund this is Chairman
Wyler's bill
we have an hb2 section 76 and if you
look at Pages 30 and 31 and on my hb2
packet you'll see the chairman Wyler
brought us an amendment that deleted the
cuts but provided funding for the
victims of this fund which the division
put in I will tell you it was one of our
few non-majority votes and we were 43 on
that but we added in into this
the hb2 packet at the very bottom of the
page you see the banking Department
although there was no change in their
budget on page 58 we of hb2 packet we
did add a new section
talking about the deposit investment
pool this was at a request of the
commissioner who said that he frequently
found himself in a conflict where he
felt like he was working against the
very people he was supposed to be
protecting he provided the language he
explained the language and we added it
to the bill
we have more Errata here
if you look at line 29 Department of
Labor
we had to change the source of fundings
they just got keyed in the wrong line so
it was an erotic sheet that was easy to
do if you look at line 32
you'll see we have a liquor and
enforcement
Amendment
and this is found in the hb2 on pages 74
and 75.
Peter leishman look worked on the
amendment you find in our packet on 77
and 81. it basically eliminates 21 Law
Enforcement Officers affected January 1
2022 it renames the division of
enforcement and Licensing and education
to the division of Licensing and
education
and as you can see it saves over 2.5
million dollars
to store operations on line 33 was again
a mistake in Keene and it was an erotic
sheet and we moved money from one place
to another no Financial impact
now we get down to the Department of
energy line 35.
it came to us it had work it really
needed quite a bit of reorganization and
the governor's budget director needs to
be credited for for working with us at
one point in time representative walls
asked if she could work with him on an
amendment and she sent him some changes
that were incorporated into the
amendment I didn't see the changes she
sent but I did see a result of the work
that was put together we also had to
move as I said earlier all of their I.T
funds back and forth line 41 we switched
positions from one account to another
account
we move funds again renewable energy
fund on line 43 out of class 47 to
consolidate the transfers Mike if you
we have administrative support consumer
Advocate and the site evaluation
committee a couple of things happened on
the site evaluation committee last
biennium they were given an HP one
footnote that said in the event the
expenditures in either fiscal year in
this accounting unit are greater than
application fees and filing fees held in
the site evaluation Committee Fund the
chairman of the site evaluation
committee May request with prior
approval of the fiscal committee that
the governor and Council authorize
additional funding that did not happen
she ignored that she needed to get prior
approval and on two separate occasions
she brought to fiscal committee rather
large bills that she had already spent
the dollars and said well you have to
fund these because we spent the money we
were fiscally conservative but we didn't
ask you for permission like where it was
supposed to so we thought we would
eliminate that this time and let them
work on this we also unfunded the vacant
this was a lot of effort I would like to
thank the committee for working through
it
going to move that now to page 53 I mean
I'm sorry line 53 Department of
Corrections
in line 54 we delayed the start of the
unclassified chairman by six months
so she is going to remain as she is
until we get into the biennium so it's a
six-month push of that
the parole board
we increase the funds in class 27 as you
can see by the amount because we did not
get the hardware and the networking and
the software charges until the very last
day that we were working
this is something we've been talking
about since November but it took a
you can see then 56 57
58.
where we put back in the transitional
housing for Shea Farm Calumet in
Manchester and then we moved
all of the Appropriations in order to
let them move so we now have
transitional housing when you turn the
page you see the rest of the impact
Mr Hoffman page eight thank you at the
top of the page to restore the operating
costs and the program coordinator
transfer positions back
for the transitional housing restores
the operating costs for the Calumet
line 65 Department of Employment
Security
while the budget has no change
page 72 in our hb2 packet
and there's a new section on fraud
Mr labors came and he talked to us
extensively about this and we put in
this section I know you've read the
newspapers about fraud in the
unemployment claims he felt that this
was needed the committee supported him
Mr Hoffman if I can go to page nine at
this point I'd be ever so happy thank
you
um Economic Development Administration
we unfunded a vacant position and pushed
again it added to our cuts
on the line four you see where we
restored the funding to the small
business
Development Center now keep in mind in
fiscal year 22 there was already fifty
thousand dollars budgeted so in that
line item in each of those two years
they will get two hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars
and we took that money as I said earlier
from the division of Tourism and travel
which you see on line five
you get now down to page line seven
Department of Natural and cultural
resources
although we made no change to their hb2
funding
there were over two million dollars
worth of parks
improvements
and if you look at page 53 in our hb2
packet
you will see that we have redone section
142.
we cut that in half
so we left new campgrounds for Jericho
we met left a new
electrical panel because the old one
will not support the campers that are
coming
and we said we're going to have to
eliminate the other three projects
since then in discussions with the
governor's budget director
chairman Weiler and I have both learned
that there is additional money for Parks
improvements in the covid bill that has
passed so what I'm expecting some of
those will be funded there and then the
Department of Environmental Services on
line 11
talks again about suspension of the
state aid grants refers you to page 19
in our packet which is section 60 that
provides the Des commissioner with the
ability to request additional
Appropriations if General funds exceed
revenue the intent was to make it very
clear that the legislative legislature
supported these programs but that gave
us the biggest amount of cuts that we
could make to support the efforts that
need to be done in division two whereas
the chairman had told me they did not
think they could make any Cuts so we
reluctantly did that but we did meet
um the needs of everybody I think in all
three divisions
there are a few sections in hb2 packet
that I haven't touched on so I'm going
to go to page 18 which is a new section
and it basically
creates a pathway for corrections
employees who've been group two
retirement to be considered for
promotions without losing their group
two benefits
and what it does oh Mike thanks for
bringing that up that's great
um
you can see in line 6 through 11 you
have some titles who have to have been
with corrections at least 15 years prior
to the appointment in the position in
order to remain in group two status and
in lines 12 through 17 some of the
positions need to be at least 10 years
line 16 prior to the appointment in the
position if they do that they can create
they can retain their group two benefits
commissioner said this would help her
greatly in retaining some of her senior
more valuable people the division talked
about it we voted this in unanimously
Mike if you go to page 33 which is
sections 102 and 105.
we're so I'm sorry Norm is not here but
this is the business profits tax credit
forward
this came from the governor
ways it means unanimously looked at this
amendment
worked on it and it was given to us to
put in to replace the sections that have
been in hb2
represent major and representative Rami
said that the their committee
unanimously felt this was The Prudent
way to move forward with this
carry forward limited payments
helps the state get on a more even
footing
representative Griffin who is a CPA and
is on division one said this is being
carry forward limits because it is
impacting the state overall financially
when you go to page 35 Mike that's
sections 114 and 1 15.
yeah this these two sections came from
BFA and we don't look at their budget
and one of the sections actually had an
effective date of May 2021 and the BFA
director was a little surprised to learn
that hb1 and hb2 didn't take effect
until July 1st so it was recommended and
I did talk to the governor's budget
director that they find a bill with
money perhaps in the senate or they
could attach those on and meet the May
implementation date that was needed
you're looking at page 39 we have
section 124
which deleted the proposal to promote
the executive assistant to a
non-classified position this is
something that should really run through
on a bill and have a job description
ready to go over so they had a little
work to look at it page 40 section 127
is really an erratic change this is
exactly what came to us in hp2 with one
exception at the end of line six and
thanks to Nancy levinas for having
caught this such per diem shall be
prorated to an hourly rate for other
related work performed by board members
that is new language it should have been
bold in nhb2 it was not Nancy Eagle I
labinos caught that and this amendment
all right Mike if we can go to page 44
sections 128
. these were deleted at the request of
I guess they didn't need them I really
don't know what we what was needed
um
we have page section 292 page 46.
this is a section that is shared by
every Division and LBA goes through and
makes sure that all the effective dates
are really effective
so you'll see this with all three
divisions these are the changes that
were needed for what we did and I thank
Nancy for doing that
if you go to Pages 60 to 65 this is a
ways and means request that came from
the chair and the vice chair and it adds
the historical racing back into
hb2 and again we had some discussion on
this the division vote on adding
historical racing was six to one so we
were not we were unanimous a lot of the
time but we were not unanimous here this
is a bill that came has my name on it
but the bills and Ways and Means came
out of ways and means and Patrick abrami
provided the language even though it has
my name on it so it talks about the
historical racing and goes the money
would go to the Lottery Commission so
this is a gain in Revenue that division
one was happy to put in for division two
but we didn't get any credit for it
against what we're trying to cut
Mike if you can bring up the pages 66 to
71 these are all the ways and means
approved sections on the BET
and again Ways and Means worked on these
the commitments in my name but I can't
take any credit for it it was just
something given to me that needed to be
put in to be corrected with what was
um
Mike if you can bring up Pages 82 to 86
this is the verbiage for
House Bill 544 this came at a request of
the leadership of our caucus again has
my name on it but I was asked to put it
in I think you've all have read it we're
getting a lot of email about it
if we can go to page 87
which is house bill
63.
and basically as you see this basically
this says this day recognizes that
multiple executive orders may have
created a new hardship or confusion we
have about ten thousand dollars in fines
outstanding this authorizes those to be
paid
um
it also lets the business who went to
court go back to court and have things
annulled if they sell shoes
Mike if you could bring up the um
Family Leave Amendment which oh let me
give you the page on that I didn't I
didn't write down that page
um
it's page 19 in the packet it's
section
69-74.
this is amended from what the governor
did
and basically this bill says and
we move the dates so everything else
medical is going to be open to everybody
it is optional it is not mandatory
it can be used for only the following
regions the birth or adoption of a child
or a serious health issue of a family
member permitted under the federal
Family and Medical Leave Act
if your company oh offer short-term
disability you must take your short-term
disability before you can apply the
family leave you can only apply for
Family Leave once a year you can take
only up to you don't have to take all of
it but up to six weeks at sixty percent
pay
again after your short-term disability
the governor proposes making this a
benefit for state employees who are
eligible for benefits there's a state
law that says you have to be working 30
hours a week to be eligible for benefits
I've heard a lobbyist has said we don't
have the people to run this well that's
actually not true because Das has an
insurance group that already runs all of
the benefits that go to our state
employees
Medical Dental workers comp all the
things runs through this Das Insurance
Group
this says that the state will have an
RFP written and they will have private
insurance companies respond to it the
governor told us 11 private insurance
companies have already made queries for
responding and again Das has a contract
group they do rfps
if you are not a state employee your
business May piggyback on this if your
business chooses not to piggyback on
this you may as an individual
contributor sign up and have family
leave
okay reasonable
yeah I have an amendment in at the
request
caucus to remove this section
I'm going through these now as requested
to go through what's in the budget and I
know you have an amendment
but I thought
I should talk about the information in
here and then you can talk about your
Amendment
thank you
um
we did two things with this we push it
so it took effect the last six months in
the biennium
and the other thing we did if you're an
individual contributor and you take your
five dollars as it came from a governor
it said
that
your business would deduct the five
dollars in payche in the insurance
company and we told the governors budget
director we were not going to do this
each of us pays for our own car
insurance so certainly if you decide to
take fmli you can afford to pay your
insurance bill for your fmly
so we did not include
the fact that they had to do it
much of the hb2 that came to us which
you've had for months stayed the same
that we looked at I have hit the things
we have deleted with one exception and I
would ask Mike Kane if he could do this
Mike we had a new
on Section 227 which was on the bill
page 105 but is an amendment in our hb2
packet of 57 the site evaluation
committee membership we had voted that
long before the rest of the Department
of energy stuff got done and this
amendment should be withdrawn and is not
needed because it was overwritten by a
subsequent vote it is still in the
packets and I assume you can make that
note somehow
yes we will make that note
representative in Mike Hoffman uh we'll
make sure that the intent of that
division of the division is reflected
thank you Mr Kane thank you Mr Hopper
all right Mr chairman that concludes my
presentation and yes I knew you had an
amendment you noticed I put family leave
last in case you wanted to submit your
Amendment next
I'll bring that up later but great job
good work for division one I'm glad you
had so much cooperation from your
members are there any questions from the
committee for representative over on the
presentation she has just made
Mr chairman
a representative leishman
thanks Mr chairman I would just like to
point out that I will be supporting the
work of division one today the chair was
correct the commission was very closely
uh I know I speak to my Democratic
colleagues that we really appreciate the
support and collaboration from our
Republican colleagues there are a few
things that I'm not happy with but I
recognize this is second base if you
will of doing it for six terms I finally
figured that out but
one of the things that is troubling is
uh House Bill 533
I'm sorry 544 which we've already
received a great deal of the email and
call us from I certainly support the
governor it has announced it the other
day that he would be total any sort of
legislation similar to this war House
Bill 544 so I'm hopeful that this
doesn't come out in the final package
but Mr chairman I want to thank the
chair of the division one for her hard
work and I think you could tell by her
presentation she's done a certain times
so so with that Mr chairman
thank you representative leishman any
questions from committee members
um Mr chair
representative hatch
thank you Mr chair if I may I I also
would like to did a representative
leachman's uh comments about uh the
chairs work in the cooperation that was
extended us within the committee um it's
a great working environment and I mean
this sincerely I I appreciate her
efforts in everybody else's efforts
unfortunately though I cannot come to a
place where I can support uh our
divisions House Bill one there's a few
items in there that are unpalatable and
I I just because they are still there
um
I cannot support it there's uh one thing
I had a lot of issues with is the
Department of energy
um it didn't belong in a budget bill
there's a it's a it's a gigantic change
administrative change within state
government it impacts multiple
departments and there's a lot of things
in that that are concerning and one one
thing that's
um
really roused my attention is many times
the individuals from the governor's
office that introduced this to us would
refer to the fact that that could be
addressed in rules and administrative
rules these are things that are lacking
within that that haven't been corrected
and aren't going to be corrected and
just just to know having been on
administrative rules for many years
having been a past chair of that
um that's not how it works we do not
legislate in administrative rules and
and it's uh problematic and what happens
often is before we can even address
something it needs the legislative fits
and that would be applicable here and
it's it's uh undoubtedly a good thing
going forward the concept of it I
support that it's obviously needed I
support that but this is really not the
way to do it and it and it doesn't
belong here and I'm very concerned about
the way it's done so that's just one of
the reasons why I can't support that
um there's there's a few other things
um uh a few of the tax reductions I
can't support
um it's funds that are needed
um they really
support the many very necessary
activities that we do as a state
government for our citizens three in
deductive funds from that they can't be
accomplished so anyways again I just
want to thank the chair for her efforts
my colleagues on the committee both
sides of the aisle I I appreciate their
efforts very much but I I just I'm sorry
I can't support this thank you Mr chair
hatch this I'm just tweaking that needs
to happen with the energy office
hopefully you can inform the Senate and
perhaps they will take up your advice
thank you Mr chair
I see a representative walls has her
hand up
representative
Mr chairman
um I too worked hard on this with
everybody else and I think that there's
a lot of good things that were done in
hb1 I'm sorry in division one but I
cannot support this and for some of the
reasons that were enumerated by
representative hatch
um without repeating a lot of them I
also have some additional issues with
this
um the problem I see with the Department
of energy is it did not have a public
hearing it did not go through a
committee there's a lot of structural
flaws with it the movement of positions
from the puc to the Department of energy
effectively eviscerates the Public
Utility Commission and means that it
will not be a well-functioning agency
we've had a well-functioning puc for a
long time we only need to look at places
like California Texas and Massachusetts
where they've had huge utility problems
where they've had inadequate regulation
to see what eviscerating the puc could
potentially do to our state and I'm very
concerned by the flaws that continue to
exist in the bill creating the
department of energy I agree overall
it's a good idea but the devil is in the
details and I don't think that this is
well executed as it stands now
I also have problems with uh with the
iteration of House Bill 544 in here and
has no business being in our laws
anywhere much less in here
um I have problems with the tax
reductions we as representative Roger
just went through and explained all the
places we are scrambling trying to find
Revenue it makes no sense to me to be
cutting our revenue and cutting
ourselves off at the knees so I cannot
support the tax cuts in here I cannot
support sending the money that's in here
to frm I mean for frm it was really a
group of people who chose to gamble with
their money didn't do their due
diligence and now they want to use
taxpayer dollars to pay them back for
their own Gamble and I cannot support
that
um
and finally I am appalled by the way
historic racing has been snuck in here
as well and has no business being in
here it's a bill that was defeated the
last well defeated once and tabled again
but stopped the last two years in the
session it was brought in at the 11th
hour with no debate and no discussion
and I think it's very poor public policy
so for those reasons among others I am
not going to be able to vote in favor of
our division one budget
uh representative I really want to make
Mr chairman I think you're going to find
that we worked well together
every budget has got things in it they
don't like I mean people hear me talk
about
the over budget at home somehow the over
budget never funds the car I want to
drive but we still go forth you have to
pick and choose what you're going to do
I am going to support the budget I plan
to support the work of division two and
three as well and I'd like to thank all
seven members of the division including
myself for the hard work because we
really did work hard thank you Mr
chairman
you representative over
now the way I'd like to do this now is
to have us vote on a report given by
division one to see which members will
support the changes and I I was going to
do just hb1 but since she reported both
hb1 and hb2 we will take separate votes
uh I'm going to ask us first to vote on
the the division one actions on HP one
and then we'll vote separately on
division actions on hb2 the clerk will
call the roll when he's ready on the
committee's response to support or
non-support uh division ones activities
on hb1 for the first vote
I will and I'm sure representative
to accept the committee work on hb1 and
representative Emrick seconds
motion
thank you Mr chair
representative Ober yes
representative umberger
yes
representative turcott representative
representative representative wrote CS
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Earth
yes
representative Griffin yes
represent Edwards yes
representative Moss
representative Lynn yes
representative norgren no
version Buco no
representative Rogers no
version of Walsh
no
representative Heath Heath votes no
representative Wilder
yes
and the emotion is adopted I'll now ask
representative over to move her report
for acceptance on hb2 so moved second
Motion in a second by representative
Uber and representative emmerich clerk
will call the role on the acceptance of
the division two action the division one
representative over yes
representative umberger
yes
representative uh turcotte yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative yes
representative Griffin yes
[Music]
representative yes
representative Lynn yes
Representative no
representative bucco no
representative leishman yeah
representative Rogers no
representative Walsh
representative Heath Heath votes no
representative Porter no
representative uh Weiler
yes
vote being 13-8 the motion is adopted
we'll move next to division two and I'll
ask representative umberger to read the
foreign
like to thank our division two members
for uh all of their hard work
and
um we were in a situation where
um unfortunately representative Daniels
is uh
not able was not able to join us and
um as a result uh representative
turcotte joined us late in the
in the budget process but uh has done a
wonderful job
I would say that uh out of our
um
committee that probably 98 of our votes
were 7-0
which
um
which as we were walking through each of
these areas uh I think that um we tried
to compromise we tried to uh make sure
that uh everyone that wanted to say how
to say and I truly appreciate all of the
uh all of the hard work that that
so if we turn to hb1
you'll notice the uh Mickey maybe maybe
you could bring up the page to help
I think everyone in the room has
a copy right
so if if we
oh
okay is that better thank you
um if you look at the first page all of
the items that are identified there are
a result of
budget entry Corrections that were
requested by the
um Department of Safety
uh
and if you um if you look at item number
yeah I'm sorry lows 42 and 40 43. this
is funding uh required to meet demand in
the uh forensic lab
and uh we felt very strongly that we did
not need to go back
to the point where our forensic lab was
not uh fully well was not funded at a
level that was appropriate
uh representative Ober had talked about
the
um
body worn and dashboard camera fund
which had originally allocated
um I'm sorry wrong wrong one the uh the
body worn and dashboard camera
uh authorized a million dollars for uh
for this to um and this is money that
the individual police departments will
be able to come into uh safety to
request support for the um body
uh
cameras and the uh dashboard cameras and
this was uh one of those items that was
recommended out of the liac commission
and what we basically did here is
um that we uh established a business
administrator position one to uh monitor
or to
to um make this program work and um
what line is that
um
46. okay I'm sorry 46
okay so that was uh basically as I said
all of the
um
areas that uh we changed in safety in
hb1 were basically a result of things
that that safety needed and I will be
discussing several other changes in
uh this is the first time in
16 years I guess that uh fish and game
uh they've they've been healthy
um
I had always we had always had to
transfer money to fish and game just so
they could uh could operate
but you will notice
um the only thing that we did or changed
in uh in fish and game was uh funding
for a
supervisory Hatchery manager and
otherwise finishing game remain the same
the Department of Transportation
unfortunately unlike the fish and game
fund the highway fund is in uh has
significant problems in funding the
things that that we need to fund to keep
our highways Bridges roads uh in good
condition as well as
maintaining uh winter maintenance which
is uh which is always a problem
so
um
basically again all of these uh items
were cuts that needed to be made in
order to balance the highway fund
and we will be talking about what we
have done to add money back into the
highway fund at a later point
but
um this is uh this was very hard on
every single one of us to think about
um cutting the the highway fund and I
will also mention
uh that um that if you look at
apportionment A and B the cut that was
uh needed there that uh that is part of
that is for uh the towns and cities the
money that they receive for
um roads and bridges in the towns
but wait till we get to hb2 okay before
you before we get to carried away with
that
so that's the highway fund uh at one
point I think we ended up with
3.86 left in the highway fund I'm just
kidding
close okay so um
but we've done some things in hb2 that
you will that will affect what's going
the Department of Education
uh had a couple of changes
uh the first one is in education
credentialing
and this is agency income
and so there's no effect on uh general
fund or the education trust fund and
they requested
um that they add a position and because
the income was such that they could that
we agreed to that
uh robotics education fund had been
funded by the governor at zero
and
um we replaced the robotics program or
we added to the robotics program
uh the 1.5 million which is what they
had had in the past and I will say that
this is probably
one of the most wonderful programs for
our high school students primarily and I
okay uh our next line
is also a
a transfer from
other agencies the first one is a
anticipated Grant from Alcohol and Other
Drugs and the uh
the second one
is
um is in again
the education trust fund
what the uh what the doe came in with uh
was not
um sufficient to cover all of the uh
uh special education requirements
and um because we were able to obtain
some
uh
General funds through some things that
we'll discuss in hb2 we are now able to
fund
um the entire requirement for the three
and a half time special education person
the college and university system uh
some of you may remember that in hb2 the
governor had proposed a
a reorganization I guess I'll call it of
the um
okay and in 2023 he had combined
the um the dollars for the University
system and the um community college
system
well we we separated those out
so that for both 22 and 23
each the universe system and the
community college system will have their
own
line item in the budget or I guess I
should call it AU and in addition to
that
um
we added
um money to both the university system
and the community college system to
bring them to the
um
2021 funding level
so that was uh that was a big jump but
and
um police standards and training
uh
the governor had uh
because of the liac committee
had appropriated
twice
funding Crisis Intervention team
training which
um the uh
police standards and training will put
together once we once we pass the budget
and provide that training to all of the
um all of the police departments
um
so on line 19 is where the community
college system received the additional
money and on page six line 23 is where
the university system
um
uh
received the uh the extra dollars
so
I think that uh hp1 work was relatively
easy I noticed Mary this is
representative Heath nodding her head HP
one was easy so
um and uh where are we
where we ran into our problems I guess
was all in hb2 but uh that's chapter two
for some other time so thank you very
much
any questions for representative
um humberger
thank you Mr
representative umberger
um the um
how stems work so well and we came to a
consensus on so many things I'm I'm
thrilled that we're able to level fund
the university and the Community College
um even more pleased that that
um we could level fund them the way they
that I had hoped we could
um we brought funding back into our
running staff program and that's an hb2
so I shouldn't talk about that but
anyway I just I want to publicly thank
the representative because
um
I truly appreciate her actions and and I
think two of us share
um uh uh caring for education and we
also care
um
specifically about the Department of
Transportation and struggle with the
moves that we had to do
um and I hope in some place in the near
future we can do something for the
Department of Transportation I worry
about a really bad storm in the winter
and all the trucks breaking down thank
you
thanks
and I don't I don't see all the faces on
the uh screen here so I can't tell if
anybody has a hand up Mickey could you
okay
representative Weiler
there are no hands raised I understood
okay and uh if you're able when we we
call on your name I'd like you to start
your video because we have a requirement
you know see where the names are
so that's us that are here okay so the
ones that are not prisoner thank you
very much all right appreciate the help
that technology I can't do this by
myself
all right so representative umberger
will you move to uh adopt your report on
hb1
and the second from representative
Petrie any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call of Rome
to accept the report for hb1 from
division two
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Ober yes
there was an umberger yes
representative turcott representative
turcott yes representative yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative erf yes representative
Griffin
yes representative Edwards
you must
representative set yes
representative Lynn yes
no
representative buco
representative hatch no
representative Rogers no
original Waltz No
version of Heath Heath votes no
representative Weiler
yes
and the motion passes I'll ask
representative to go over the division
two report for
hb2
okay
um
[Music]
on p on section 45 the uh the governor
had recommended that we use the 19
figure to uh for free and reduced lunch
to compute the
um
the aid for schools
and
um we accepted that
uh we also moved uh the tobacco
settlement funds uh into uh into hb2 for
some reason or other they weren't there
the public school infrastructure fund
had 30 million dollars in each of the
two years
and
um
primarily
because the
latest
um
what's it called American Recovery Act
uh the uh we were basically informed
that many of the projects that were
uh that would qualify for
um
the public infrastructure program could
in fact be funded by the American
Recovery Act
and as we looked at
um
what is currently
on hold because there wasn't enough
money
that we believe that the public
infrastructure fund could move to move
down to a million dollars a year
which left us with um
29 million in each of the two years
to use for
um other areas other things
within the um
within the uh education area that we did
not feel were
funded at the um
appropriate level
but by leaving the million dollars in
there
we were in fact able to keep this
program
uh viable
and I think that that is um
that is something that is uh extremely
important
uh otherwise the
um the program some of you may remember
uh that we had this this public
infrastructure program was set up
um I believe three or three years ago
anyhow to take care of problems that the
schools were having with safety and
internet connection so
um that uh that remains
um
as it was so there's there is money to
as I said the crisis intervention team
appropriation we uh we deleted that
the college and university system Board
the sister yeah then yeah and the uh
Community College
system
the governor had
basically recommended that we
abolish the two separate boards and form
a new Board of Trustees
consisting of 15 people
uh five people from the University board
five people from the community college
um
um I don't know 10 12 14 20 hours later
I have no idea how much time we spent on
this along with our friends in uh
on the education committee also spent a
lot of time providing uh input to us and
they they in fact held a uh a
subcommittee meeting that made
several recommendations
uh to uh to us that were then
Incorporated so to speak within the um
within the change to hb2 uh
representative turkot since you were
kind of the um
time motivator behind what we finally
ended up with in hb2 could you just give
us a little description of what is now
in hb2 dealing with uh the merger of the
two University Systems
certainly uh representative
um
maybe the best place to start is the
reason why we ended up here and that was
uh the current language in hb2 a lot of
us felt uh was moving the process a
little bit too fast I personally had
concerns with the
the idea of creating a
15-member a Board of Trustees
uh that would be put to uh immediately
go to work on
implementing this merger
I I thought it was something that needed
to be slowed down something that the
public needed a little bit more input on
and that that thought was shared by many
members on the committee so what I did
instead is we got together and
kind of we formed a commission rather
than changing over to a Board of
Trustees right from the Out start
I'll go over basically what kind of
changed in it we went from a 15-member
Board of Trustees down to an 11 member
Board of commission Commissioners
four from the University of New
Hampshire four from the community
college system and ultimately three by
the governor we had had some
intermittent intermediate talks where
possibly some legislators were being be
involved but we decided in the end to go
with the three members appointed by the
governor for a total of 11.
um
and the idea of the commission was to
get together and actually look at the
possibility not the not predetermined
that it had to be done but the
possibility of merging the two College
systems
um
if you look on page nine of our packet
really the
some of the important stuff is on begins
on line number 12 and that basically
gives the commission uh until January 1
of next year
the time to look at uh look over
everything determine if legislation uh
is actually needed to merge the two
systems
and if that were the case they would of
course produce legislation it would come
before uh committees and then uh uh
possibly be implemented on July 1st of
2023. you'll notice there's a laundry
list of items beginning in line 17 on
page nine
um
issues that we believe they should look
at and incorporate into any legislation
and a last-minute Edition was if you
look online
37 and that that was the final report of
the study group
for
post-secondary education that we
received just a couple days prior to
this amendment being drafted and uh it
was included in there if you if you look
at it the first six pages of the report
are excellent and they're mainly all
questions questions that are unanswered
about what this is going to look like
how it's going to work all issues that
we believe should be included
um you know prior to establishing a
Board of Trustees something that
uh
anyway that that particular issue really
needs to be I think uh above all in the
laundry list that really needs to be
um regarded it was an excellent report
um
last thing uh we discussed was different
dates about uh when it would take effect
and we ultimately in the final line
there
we decided that the best would be that
it re uh take effect upon the passage
also appropriation in line 13 that was a
number suggested by the chair of our
committee I I really had no comment one
way or another on it so that was uh put
in on the chairs requests
um other than that in the end I think we
did very well with it we came out uh
unanimous out of our committee was seven
to zero uh everybody didn't get
everything they wanted
but I think everybody got some of what
they wanted there were a lot of
competing interests as I've noted before
but I think in the end we produce
something that's reasonable thank you
thank you very much Rosa representative
turcotte I know that uh every
one on that on the committee worked hard
to make sure that uh that we got
something in here
okay
um
the commission uh going down to um
sections 145 through 148.
uh this is a commission to uh study
establishment of a Statewide entity to
receive complaints of misconduct
Appropriations
and um
safety and the Attorney General
are to get together
to figure out what this uh
commission was going to look like and uh
they had asked for five five positions
and this was even before they figured
out what the um
what the commission might look like what
it might do or any number of other
things so
um
we reduce the we reduce the
this by um
I think it was
well we reduced it to one
one hundred thousand dollars which
the state scholarship program
uh the governor had wanted money in
there to
um pay off student loans
and as a committee we didn't think this
was the best use of the money that we
would rather provide it on the front end
to our New Hampshire students rather
than on the back end to Workforce
develop Workforce paying off student
loans and there was uh so anyhow that's
what that's what we did and we also
added
in here that um the governor's
scholarship program
will be
managed in the same way
as the unique program
in the higher education
Commission
so there's uh there's money money
available there
okay the next was uh dual and concurrent
enrollment
once again an extremely popular uh
program among High School juniors and
seniors
and the governor had
funded it at zero
and we uh did two things
the first thing is the uh
Commissioner of education did not feel
that he should act as a pass-through for
this money
and so we checked with the Community
College to see if they would be willing
to uh
administer if that's the right term this
program and they agreed to that and we
put in uh 1.5
million dollars in each uh each year of
the biennium to
Community College thinks it will fully
fund if that's the right term whatever
whatever that means but we we anticipate
being able to um
completely fund uh the Dual and
concurrent enrollment program
uh
next we added a section from
the
5 594 is that the right number
that talked about
um
a 10-year plan for Grant projects for
school building and so what this does is
that it encourages the local school
boards to look out for 10 years as to
what kinds of things are they going to
require that they want state aid for and
the other half of that is that it allows
the allows doe to know
where things are going with uh with
school building eight so we thought that
that was uh that was excellent
uh last year
oh two years ago excuse me
uh what
kindergarten adequate education grants
got left out for several
communities that were starting up
kindergarten
and so
um
we the Senate came over and asked us if
we would include that in our budget and
okay
uh
[Music]
we
these last these last three
amendments
or the last I guess I should say the
last
oh I forgot uh representative Weiler
wanted it and wanted an amendment
dealing with how people how vacancies
are filled on Cooperative School
District boards and that amendment made
made sense to uh to all of us
okay
120 or yeah one zero two seven
and
one zero two three
two two I'm sorry three two I must be
dyslexic
um
the uh
Ways and Means As We Know
get uh to project that there would be
um
additional dollars available
and what came to the uh education trust
fund
was 44 million dollars
money that we then had to had to spend
oh well we didn't have to spend it but
we didn't think it needed to sit around
when we had necessary needs
uh
the speaker this is all part of that
money that we were that Ways and Means
was able to provide
uh the speaker
then provided us with another 100
million dollars
which came to 144 million
and the purpose of this hundred million
is to reduce the swep payments that
individual towns will be making
and the state will then
you know provide the money that they
would have collected
so I had we so the the speaker was going
to have a well we were going to transfer
100 million we had 44 million so we said
look
we'll keep the 44 million and Mr Speaker
only give only you know transfer the 63.
so I mean it's it's all the same it all
works out the same but we were going to
transfer 44 million over to the general
fund
okay and then transfer back in 100
million which
really didn't make sense and so uh
Mickey
in his wonderful way
uh suggested that uh that this is uh
This Is How We Do It
so
the 44 million that we're talking about
that um
ends up
and now go you know the switch if you
I think the amenities uh Amendment 1032h
which is page number 30 in the House
thank you I just didn't turn the page
so what this money that we're talking
about will
uh be used for
is
um
four million
for
apportionment a
and this is the distribution to the
towns and cities
the gas tax collections are down
significantly
and
um apportionment a or Highway block
grants
are provided to the towns based on
three cents of every dollar collected in
the road toll
so
when the road toll is down the money
that goes to the towns and cities is
also down
so this four million dollars uh allows
us to get us back pretty much to where
we were in uh 20.
uh so
the the towns and cities will not be
seeing a decrease in that
uh we put 5 million into the betterment
program
dot had expressed that because the gas
tax was down and this is 12 cents of
every dollar of gas tax
that
they would not be able to continue their
betterment program
at the same level as they had in the
past
and so
Paving roads fixing Bridges doing all of
those things are
extremely important uh for the state and
so we put another
five million into that
we also put 6 million into acquisition
of uh equip
vehicles and Equipment
um safety or safety
Transportation had had had
to cut
um
the uh money for uh
equipment
significantly and it would have would
have caused some some real problems in
keeping up with their vehicle purchase
program and so we put uh six million
dollars
into into that
and then if you'll notice in HP one I
said I took money away from Winter
maintenance and that just wait I would
put it back which I have done here in uh
in hb2
Okay so
there was still dollars out of this 44
million that arrived in the education
trust fund
and so what we did
is that we put
uh
uh into
is that right yeah we put that into the
bill building aid program
uh for
um
I'm sorry that's yeah 19 million is what
we put in for
um new projects
and then
is it 20 29 million I think was the
figure
that
um Department of Education
owes to
school systems that have bonds that go
out until
2042.
so we talked to doe to see if there was
any way we could accelerate those
programs those Bond payments
to get us not to have to continue paying
this and reducing the amount of building
Aid that we might have available in the
future
and they said yes that could be done
and so we placed
um eight million dollars
against reducing those
uh we've got too many tales out there so
I don't like to call it the tail but
this is to pay off
uh school systems for outstanding bonds
that they have
and uh then that will allow in the next
biennium you know another
8 million plus whatever they're paying
off this year to hopefully go into into
okay
so how hopefully
that
covers everything like I said we were
we were
razor laser focused on hb2 because this
is where you know where we had uh
we had our we had our problems and uh I
would say that all of the Departments
came in to us
with extremely lean budgets
and um
and I know that uh that I appreciated it
and that's when uh representative Weiler
asked me if I could cut any general
funds and I think we ended up with
1.5 million reduction in general funds
each year of the biennia so I did
contribute just a little bit but again
division two is is primarily made up of
uh Highway funds education funds Fish
and Game fund and so the uh our share of
uh General funds is very limited but
again I want to thank everybody for all
of the hard work on division two and I
left out Mick landrigan the first time
and
I'll tell you what this guy is a genius
okay when it comes to all of the issues
that we have to deal with and uh he
makes he makes my job and the job of
everyone else on the committee so easy
so thank you all for uh for listening
and um I hope that I've covered
everything that uh that needed to be
covered
[Music]
representative umberger are there any
questions
thank you Mr chair and I too um like
Mickey has just been beyond the Beyond
wonderful he just is amazing what he can
do
um first I want to thank representative
uh turquoit II for all his help on that
um Amendment it was wonderful that he
took the lead on that and though we
didn't agree on everything I think we
came out to where we wanted to be and
representative
umberger thank you we accomplished so
much uh so many of the things that were
so critically important
um I just we got to the end we had
agreed on so much and and there's so
many things that actually it makes me
there are pieces of me that struggle
um with not supporting this this budget
um but I just can't because of the final
um amendment that we passed um to send
the 100 million to swept uh to reduce
taxes when I desperately believe that
money could so much better be used going
in fact to the adequacy and and
restoring those funds to the school
districts especially after the covet
pandemic but again I just want to thank
you all and please know how much I
anyone else with a question or statement
representative Petrie thank you Mr
chairman yeah I want to thank our
chairman uh representative umberger we
had a real bipartisan effort it was
great our substitutes were absolutely
fantastic and I can Echo the uh Mickey
Lincoln I tell you he's amazing he
really is and uh really appreciate him
thank you uh representative Weiler I I
have an amendment to offer I'm sorry did
Vicki did that Amendment get here uh yes
the amendment is up uh posted online I
can also share it and it was emailed to
the entire committee yesterday uh so
amendment number
um zero three five each replace
1033h which is the last amendment in the
amendment packet I defer to the chair
how you want to handle that if you want
to swap that out prior to taking the
full division two
um action
it's truly a technical amendment that
lines up with what the intent of
changes
okay
Mickey would you like to just
I can I can do it but I I would love to
have you take care of that
so
um with the 100 million dollar sweat
reduction Amendment
uh in fiscal 23. as we all know uh the
Statewide education property tax is part
of the
formula for determining total education
grants the intent of division two was to
essentially buy down the amount the
amount of swept required to be raised in
that one year through an infusion of
General funds
um we didn't consider any unintended
consequences to Total education grants
to any cities and towns so if you look
on this amendment section two you will
see here that in the event
total education grants are negatively
impacted through this wept reduction in
fiscal 23 the Department of Education
would provide a supplemental payment to
any affected cities and towns to make
sure that this action would have no
as part of your package you're
substituting this new Amendment as the
last page
is that supported by hb2 or our
correction division two members support
it
can I say hb2 can you show my show of
okay
and I think I'm looking for
representative buco
a representative
um
representative Porter do you support it
do not okay
uh what I hope to do is minimize the
roll calls but I think you have to do a
roll call because of the zoom sir yeah
all right so
for the substitution of the amendment
1035 H
1035h to report uh represent umbergamos
representative Petrie seconds that 1033
be replaced by 1035.
uh representative Wilder I would assume
do we need the entire committee to agree
to that or just division two oh and
we're going to do the whole entire
committee to agree to that okay fine
clerical column on that substitution of
amendments
thank you Mr chairman Rosen of Ober yes
yes representative umberger
yes Arizona turkoff yes
representative yes representative Petrie
votes yes representative Emrick yes
representative URF yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Edwards yes president who
said yes
representative Lynn yes
representative norburn
no
representative Buco no
Representative leishman no
representative hatch no
represent Rogers no
representative Waltz No
Arizona Heath he folks no representative
Porter no
Mr chairman the vote is 12-9 he affirmed
that you
passes okay 12 to 9 the amendment is
adopted and now uh representative
umberger moves the actions of
division two for hb2 be accepted by the
full committee and representative Petrie
seconds and the clerk will call a role
is there any further discussion on that
motion
wanted to reiterate what my colleagues
have said about the collegiality of
division two and the welcoming nature
and the hard work that we did I
appreciated being accepted into the
group and um
tweeted fairly and openly and got my
voice heard uh thank you to uh champ
representative umberger and to the
financial
legislative budget assistance and and
Mickey and and all I appreciate it I'm
sorry I'm not going to be able to
support the final project for the same
reasons that representative Heath has
has iterated already thank you
thank you for joining us
any further discussion seeing none the
clerk will call the roll on the
acceptance of The Division II hb2
actions as amended
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Ober yes
there's a umberger
yes representative church I post yes
representative yes
represent Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Earth yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Morris representative
Lynn yes
representative walner
Representative norgren no
representative bucco no
Representative leishman no
representative hatch no
representative Rogers
representative walls
representative Heath he fought now
representative Porter no
and representative Weiler
yes
Mr chairman of vote is 12-9 any
affirmative
well being 12-9 the motion is adopted uh
timing is just about perfect
we will take uh lunch break until one
o'clock and then we'll commence with
division three reports
all right thank you all for your
attendance
so
when the clerk is ready we'll call the
roll
knowing that there are 15 of us in reps
fix that are
that are on Zoom
I guess Mr chairman uh clerk will call a
roll thank you
[Music]
president of Ober yes I'm here
representative umberger
here
representative president
representative Petrie's here
representative Emrick here
representative
[Music]
representative Griffin
representative Edwards Edwards is here
well
uh
all right well that worked out well
representative Lynn here
she's online is she have we got any uh
can they hear us
make sure is represented an order near
uh Mr chairman
was here we look like we've lost her
yeah
okay
uh representative organ is here yeah she
answered okay I'm sorry I can't hear
representative Buco president
thank you representative leishman
representative hatch
representative Rogers
okay
representative walls
representative Heath okay thank you and
representative
who's in for Murray uh Porter I I'm here
good to know that
the chairman is 19th president we have a
quorum
thank you
all right continuing our reviews of the
budget by division
we'll next call upon representative
Edwards
the chairman of division three for his
remarks on hb1
thank you Mr chairman uh if we could do
a share screen to show what I refer to
as a horse blanket the the long document
that's entitled division three category
five house finance versus Governor
detail change
there it is there it is okay so
um this is a combination of some policy
uh changes that we made as we went
through hb1 and I think some technical
changes that were made by the DHHS
Finance in conjunction with our LBA so
I'll uh spend more time talking about
what we did as a matter of policy I
think uh as a matter of context it's
worth noting that division three is a
very large and complex Department over
two-thirds of the funds that we have to
appropriate are actually from the
federal government so General funds
represents less than a third of what the
department spends
some major assumptions that we made for
this budget cycle is that when we went
into it we assumed that we were working
from the ways and means estimate that we
voted on in the last house session
we assume that even though we knew that
there would be another round of cares
act money maybe as much as just a just
under a billion dollars we didn't count
on any of that billion dollars as
helping with the the mission that we
were looking to fund
um we looked at the enhanced
Medicaid match and
um recognized that that would probably
continue for the first six months of the
first fiscal year so there were several
accounts that rely on Medicaid match
right now there's an enhanced match
that's taking place which lets more
Federal money go against our budget
rather than General funds so that that
helped us so we've taken advantage of
that accounting we've also
um uh
we've also take taken a large number of
departments that were federal funds only
or other agency funds only and basically
just accepted them uh without any
significant debate
so so that gets us into this uh this
first line uh this is a fairly major
policy decision that was made and uh
these first accounting uh numbers uh
from one through 15 reflect that the
policy decision was to uh essentially
have legislature legislature driven
closure of the sununu center and I I
pointed out as legislative uh lead
driven because this was not in the
Department's recommendation so so
um in a very bipartisan way
the the funds that you see removed in FY
23 are related to the sununu center
um there should be another three million
dollars that will come across somewhere
in here 2.6 million to um to provide
some ongoing funds so that they can
transition
um next down on line 21 this is an
example of adding back money for uh
extending the assumptions around
fmap the enhanced fmap
in the acronyms they're Federal Medical
Assistance percentage
uh so so that it shows a deckerman and
general funds and an increase in federal
funds of about 2.3 million
um the next one
line 23 represents a decision to take
out of the operating funds out of hb1 25
million for the biennium this is uh
money that was meant to pay for the
Medicaid management information system
to to to have the Legacy system run in
parallel while they phase in the new
system so rather than having uh
effectively a one-time expense reflected
as operating funny money we moved those
funds over to
hb2 for uh 25 million for the biennium
uh when we did that
um uh we ended up making it appear as
though we were decreasing federal funds
to the tune of 67 million and the
reality is that we will still have
access to that money it's just Federal
money that will have to be picked up by
The Joint legislative committee uh later
but those funds are going to be
available for the Medicaid management
information system transition from
Legacy to a new system
on the second page line 28
this is a fairly significant policy
decision
um under the current law the the uh the
administration the executive branch was
only responsible for funding the first
five million dollars to help the
counties pay for some nursing home
expenses
and uh and then historically there's
been something called a county cap where
um subsequently in the budget process
money was added back and it historically
the counties have been expecting about a
three three percent per year increase in
their the amount that they need to pay
well what we did this term was we added
back
um uh so that it effectively will reduce
the County's obligation to uh two
percent growth and that's significant
because as we got testimony from
um from Rockingham County and
Hillsborough County in Rockingham County
for example had we not done anything it
would have forced the county to raise
their property tax Portion by seven
percent so so although it doesn't look
like a uh property tax decrease to the
naked eye this is effectively us funding
um uh relief for County property taxes
it's something to keep your your eye on
as it goes through the Senate
line 33 this is 50 000 in general funds
that we added back and or added in FY 22
to the Family Planning money this fifty
thousand dollars is to be made available
to
um to assist in stimulating competition
for new family uh planning uh program
clinics
so that that uh that 50 000 could be
seen either as a bonus to get to
stimulate new competition or if there's
a new awardee then there's some money
there for them to help with the first
time startup costs
under the
line 45 down there this is uh also
enhancements from the uh the the higher
than usual uh uh medical assistance
going on the last row of the previous
page down to row 48.
um this is I think
this is also related to the fmap from
above and the next lines are as well so
all of these different lines are
Medicaid related and so they benefit
from having a higher Medicaid match
down on line 55
um
this was I don't really know the right
way to exp to couch it whether it was an
error or an oversight or a mistake or
whatever but the reality is there was a
9.1 million dollars that we were
expecting to come from another line to
help with the New Hampshire hospital and
um and because that was a mistake we
ended up adding 9 in general funds to
cover it
the next line 59 and 60. these are
related there's a a system out there
that shares admissions
discharges and transfer uh hl7 messages
in between a bunch of interconnected I.T
systems in the communities and this is a
I.T system that helps coordinate care
out into the community
as patients move about this this is the
opposite of what we did with the
Medicaid management information system
this is actually an ongoing program that
should not have been in hp2 so we moved
it over to HP one and in doing so that
revealed that there was uh 600 000
matching from federal money the the
extra 6 1608 was a typo that a one of
our accountants found and she used this
opportunity to fix that but it's really
a 200 000 transfer of General funds and
a six hundred thousand gain and
um
in uh Federal matching
on the next page
[Music]
we
were able to fund two temporary
positions in child protection using a
hundred percent federal funds
um that wasn't really a Division III
decision it was more of a DHHS find
after the budget had been submitted and
so we accepted it same thing with the
sixty thousand dollars there for an a
grant award
um
there were some other technical
adjustments made starting on line 71
and running down
um
until we get to
down to line
80. those those are technical
adjustments
um then when we get to line 81 this is
this tiny four dollar change is just
killing an account that we no longer
need when we get to line 82
um this is money that's going to help
fund mobile crisis
um
centers they're they're basically uh
Decked Out vans that can help provide
mobile psychiatric services around the
state this this will bring the total
number of mobile crisis centers uh up to
five and
um these are really a great Gap filler
in terms of the clinical whole that that
we've had in our Behavioral Health
Network and uh I I do think that in the
years to come we really need to um make
sure that these continue to be a good
investment because we are investing a
lot of money in these and so continuing
to keep our eye on the ball here will
will matter
um and then from line
83 down uh were or is that 83 that's 84.
84 down we're uh transferring some audit
positions around between accounting
units
um I think that accounts for everything
down to line
95 and then 95 were just adjusting a
source of funds to recognize
administrative fees that were earned in
that account
and then the last page uh 96 is just the
the opposite of that transfer just to
show the funds moving from A to B and Mr
chairman with that uh I've completed the
briefing on the changes in hp1 from
thank you representative Edwards are
there any questions
foreign
[Music]
yes we can hear you
all right it's a line 64 refers to
a 226
position
um being eliminated at Health and Human
Services
which equals about
22.6 million dollars
and it should be should be also noted
that in the governor's budget he had
eliminated 88 positions
so for a total of 314.
is with the total elimination of
positions
in the department these are back of the
budget
reductions so so the numbers you're
referring to I I don't see on the horse
blanket for line 55 and
there there are no numbers that I see on
line
54.60 that would make a difference
[Music]
okay so
um I was going to
um
take after this horse blanket I was
going to speak to this other document
where all the amendments are included
and so so the amendment that you're
referring to is also going to be
discussed here in a moment in the in the
next set of of
hp2 amendments
well these are both back of the budget
yeah and the back of the budget cut is
is is referred to in this package
related to hb1 I just think it should be
no I I can do those now
um there is there is a a package uh that
the division three has uh called house
finance division three uh House Bill one
and two proposed amendments uh there are
uh two new sections added you can see
them there
um and then you can go to the next page
um what what this uh Amendment 51 did
and I can see why it's appropriate to
talk about it now thank you so much for
doing that
um uh we
if you look at how many people there
were in the department as of 11 March
there was
2651 people and this is going to be a
lot of numbers for those paying
attention at home so
um so they have a tremendous number of
vacancies
every single Department
reported well pretty much every single
Department reported having a difficult
time because New Hampshire has severe
Workforce shortages in health care
providers people who in our delegations
work with our nursing homes and people
on HHS who work with Workforce issues
for Health Care also know that Statewide
we have a very significant problem with
they're just not being enough health
care providers in our in our system to
um to to fill every position that's
needed between the state between the
counties between the local civilian
Health Care Facilities we're all
competing for the same people so what
hb1 this amendment uh
0936 does is it recognizes that
we could in theory try to hire thousands
of more people but in reality the number
that we can actually hire is much limit
much more limited because there is a
Workforce shortage and competition
across the entire Health Care delivery
spectrum and so with an authorization
that came over of three thousand two
hundred and twenty six positions of
which 88 were unfunded
if you subtract that 88 you're down
around 31.40
and then when you take a look at the
fact that we are as a policy decision
have decided to close the sununu center
that will free up another 96 people so
if you if you take that 88 and that 96
then we're down to 3042. uh this hp1
recognizes those reductions and then
takes an additional 42.
so to make it an even three thousand now
what does that 3000 represent well given
the current vacancy rate as of 11 March
over the approximately
350 vacancies the department can go out
and fill 88 percent of them
before they hit the ceiling so so while
it looks like a reduction on paper I
think in reality
there is a tremendous amount of hiring
new hires that the department can do
and I think there's anyone who's ever
worked in a corporation knows uh when
you hire a large contention of new
people it takes a very long time to get
them
trained and acclimated to the work
culture and the environment and becoming
productive and so hp1 in my view is
recognition of the reality that the
workforce is limited and the department
still has in reality a lot of room to
grow before they hit this new threshold
don't answer your question
yes and and the next section 65 I think
it's hard to hear you I'm sorry 65.
so is that is is that the uh the
financial cut yes okay so so then
um uh thank you for the question the if
you go back a page whoever's doing the
screen did you go back a page real quick
uh the other way somebody who's doing
the screen sharing go back
okay so then the second line item these
two are really uh twins they they go
they their sign meets twins they go
together
um the the um the budget reduction so so
now we can go to page three on the
screen share to see the amendment
and what this does is it um
recognizes that the department uh can
manage a higher lag and make some
priority decisions on where to focus
their resources and so in the first year
of the budget it
um requires the back of the budget
reduction of 30 million dollars
uh and in the second year 20 million for
50 million for the biennium and uh in
doing so we prioritized and there's a
lot of words here but I'm just you know
so just generally the description is we
per we prioritized
direct Health Care Services
where there is a patient that needs
treatment we've protected the governor's
budget and those to to be specific those
areas include all developmental services
to include acquired brain disorders and
children's In-Home Support Services the
children's health insurance program and
the county programs to include the state
share of funding for nursing facilities
another long-term care facilities such
as the CFI program so we we in this
amendment are protecting
every place that the department is
paying for direct health care for New
Hampshire's beneficiaries which which
leaves them an opportunity to prioritize
among their other programs and and
invest where they need to now this is
still more money than they're going to
spend in the current year
um when it all said and done it's not as
big as their budget for the current year
but it's but when we look at the actual
spending this is a higher budget than
that
um
what else did I want to say about that
[Music]
I think those are my main points do you
do you have a follow-on
no I'm sure that we've covered this
right okay
before I come to representative hatch
I've been watching representative
nordgren has her hand up so
representative nordgren and then
representative hatch
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
representative Edwards for your
presentation
um I did want to clarify for the other
members of the committee uh when you
spoke uh about the amendment on page
three uh
about the Personnel related
Appropriations and the number of
positions that were being deleted
um I think you
uh we're erroneous in one of your
comments this sununu Center employees on
page 29 of House Bill 2 are given
priority for being hired and we're
hoping to retrain those people who lose
their employment there so I don't think
they should be counted in that number
um we're hoping they're not
um I also wanted to call a question on
page two
um
row 33 Family Planning program
um I don't really have any definition of
what providers would be awarded this
money I don't see anything that
clarifies it in House Bill 2 I was just
hoping for clarification of what sort of
uh people you would want to
attract to receive these funds thank you
okay so I'll do that second question
first
um if um when we were reviewed and
approved this in committee there was a
footnote associated with it in hb1 and
the footnote I'm not seeing the footnote
there but the footnote as I recall
stipulated that
no more than ten thousand dollars could
be granted per
new awardee uh of a contract so so the
idea is if if you're a
federally funded health clinic and you
haven't been competing for State Family
Planning dollars if you became a
competitor and you were to win a bid and
you were new then there there might be
some one-time costs associated with
getting into the program that that that
up to ten thousand dollars would defray
or otherwise it would serve as a bonus
to increase competition and that that
line was in
um the footnote for hb1
thank you may I ask a further question
sure so so just a clarification so these
organizations would have to previously
or currently have Federal funding for
their organization Federal Government
funding no it's just that the these
would be new awardees of state federal
state Family Planning programs that's
what that footnote says
but we don't have any other criteria an
example of one that could compete not
that that's an exhaustive list
but pretty much anyone who wants to
compete for Family Planning counseling
and programs if they're a new awardee
they would be eligible for up to ten
thousand dollars per awardee new awardee
[Music]
and that that was in the footnote that
we reviewed in division three committee
that was part of the discussion on on
that line item
yes I see it here in my papers thank you
sure
or are they said other questions on HP
one yes
all right represent if you are you
finished representative yes thank you
[Music]
changing just as long
as well performance between the
so that's all that you are saying
correctly there is an alignment to be
hospitals other health care providers
IP and nurses
physical therapists excellent
Technologies
Healthcare professionals
so they aren't
okay go back to high school algebra
where they had a Venn diagram and I
think
no I I I'm just trying to answer your
question for the other people who are
sorry to cut cut off but on Zoom we
could not hear representative hatch's
question I don't know if he's near a
microphone but I'll repeat uh
representative hatch's question as I
understand it since he doesn't have a
microphone
um but the question is I understand it
is I made a comment that New Hampshire
has Workforce shortages and that there's
uh competition for scarce Manpower
between the state agencies County
agencies and civilian Health Care
organizations and so his question was
meant to clarify my remark to whether or
not there was an exact overlap between
the types of people that the state needs
to hire in the DHHS and those that are
needed by the counties and by the
civilian providers and so he's asking me
to clarify that is that a fair
characterization okay so representative
Patrick grease that that's a fair
summary
and so I I would go back to anyone who's
seen those Venn diagrams where there's
two different sets and they they have an
overlap in the middle and they have
differences on in each of the sets as
well and so that that kind of classic uh
two set Venn diagram I think would help
graphically
represent part of the answer is that
there is a tremendous amount of overlap
the the more that you get on to direct
Hands-On providers like nurses
behavioral specialists
LPNs and the like then then yeah there's
a whole lot of overlap now now in the
um at the state level you can see more
administrators you can also see a lot of
Public Health Specialists
and so there there is a distinction also
in the um
from the state to the civilian health
care provider but but there's a
tremendous amount of overlap and and I
think I think the bigger point a bigger
point that that needs emphasis is that
the entire state is suffering from a
long-term chronic
issue we're just not having enough
health care providers in the state to
meet all the demands of all of the jobs
and and I for one would rather to have
scarce medical resources out in the
communities touching patients rather
than in a department
on the phone you know coordinating care
between other care providers I I I have
a bias towards direct Hands-On Health
Care
he does not think that answered his
question really but I'm just repeating
all right we have representative Porter
with her hand up and representative
noidgren your hand is still up is there
yes I had a follow-up question but you
can take representative Porter first
all right representative Porter for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative Edwards I'm not sure
you can answer this question for me I
know at the county level we have
struggled with um
getting people to work in our nursing
home for example
um is there a does the state set a
certain pay scale
which the anybody that has Medicaid
reimbursement needs to follow or are
the County's free to pay what they want
versus the state
DHHS pay what they want is that does
that question make sense I guess my
question is is there a unified pay scale
you know health care workers you're
asking me a question that I'm a little
leery to answer because I I think I know
about a 90 answer your question I'm not
a I'm not a Medicaid billing expert and
so if you'll accept a little bit of
Tolerance in my answer the way it is
essentially is that the providers set
their rates uh based on what they what
they think they they need to charge and
and different payers will
um
reimburse their rates based on their own
formulas commercial insurance companies
tend to pay the best uh and then
Medicare uh pays less but Medicaid pays
the least and so in general the Medicaid
rate is set whether it's set at the
state level or set at the federal level
that's where I'm a little
um you know gray I'm not sure but it but
the the Medicaid rate scale gets set by
a central entity working for one of the
government levels and I believe a few
years ago
New Hampshire
uh established that we would pay the
same Medicaid rate throughout the state
that we wouldn't have distinctions for
Manchester versus Coos County I believe
that's true I remember that I think for
my HHS days
um there's another thing that's really
close to what you're asking and that is
uh does the state ever
decide to enter into a rate agreement
with different kinds of care providers
and in fact we do and uh we have a
program called CFI and for some the
representative Waller can you refresh me
on what CFI means
um
choices for Independence choices for
Independence thank you sir uh choices
for Independence is a program that that
helps the elderly stay in their home for
a longer period of time before going
into a Skilled Nursing Facility so these
choices for Independence uh help the
families uh keep mom and dad at home
longer and and but do show up regularly
to provide care and support the state
has set the rate for those kinds of
services in one of the discussions that
we had in this cycle was whether or not
the the rate that has recently been
increased is really going to be enough
and and so we're we're actually
intending to work uh provide our
community for CFI and the Senate to see
if they may be able to improve upon the
rate that's been established so so it's
it's at least a couple different ways
and and I hope that answers your
question because I can't possibly tap
dance on that answer any longer
thank you
representative neudgren for a question
thank you very much
um I just wanted to go back to
representative
um Edwards and my concern about
the issue
of the Personnel issue in the sununu
center I think I'm not sure you answered
that question of my concern that we
shouldn't be counting them in our list
of the number of employees that will be
um cut because I I'm thinking we don't
want that to be something they would be
concerned about because it is in-house
Bill 2 on page 29. so we'll try to
relocate them or give them training for
other jobs in the state thank you right
so so what I was trying to explain with
that and and thank you for asking me to
clarify because it can't it can and
should be clarified and that is that the
vacancy rate at the sununu center was
was relatively small and then they were
authorized about 96 people so that's 96
people who are currently state employees
that once the sununu center closes uh
those positions there will no longer be
authorized in the second year of this
budget but you're absolutely right we
made it a priority to retain and retrain
those people and so so the point I was
trying to make earlier is that that's
that's Manpower that's going to be freed
up for the commissioner to reprogram the
higher priority needs and so so that
that that was really my point is that
for the folks who are concerned about
um the head count being lower than the
governor's budget I would say you know
it's mitigated to an extent because here
are 96 positions that can be reallocated
the people can stay they just need to be
retrained and re you know cross-trained
and and Rec categorized in some cases
representative leishman for a question
thanks Mr chairman and uh thank the
chair of division three for taking my
question
so we've often heard that New Hampshire
is a state that sends more money to
Washington than we ever get back
and I was looking at line 105 as far as
federal funds and I see for the biennium
there's 77 million dollars in federal
funds it would be cut is this just
increasing the amount of money we send
to Washington or maybe you could explain
the 77 million
now that might impact what we're sending
to Washington and getting back
all right you you may remember
when I was talking about the Medicaid
management information system and how we
would be moving it from hp1 to hp2
okay so so when you move it from HP one
to hp2
hb2 does not recognize the federal funds
that go with it and I tried at the time
just when I was talking about it to say
that it looks like it's a really big cut
in federal funding but in fact it's not
because the joint legislative
fiscal committee can will still accept
that Federal money so the vast majority
of this total of 77 million dollars is
related to money that we're still going
to bring in to the state
through that hp2 trans transfer now if
I'm not sitting at a desk where I can
flip through this stuff quickly but let
me try to find the exact number like if
you go to line 24 on page one of that
horse blanket down at the bottom it says
67.6 million
that that
67.6 million looks like a cotton federal
funds
but it's it's it's not it's just taking
it off of the hb1 spreadsheet because
we'll still get it
through the joint Crystal kinetic so so
that 67.6 million Finds Its way to that
line 105.
in that line 105 again I'm just flipping
through paper here
is 77 million so all but 10 million
pretty much is explained by that one
transaction
and and and and frankly I'm not prepared
to answer where the other 10 million
what's going on with the other 10 money
you want to grab his mind oh yeah my
question is a quick one
um just simply usually
um working in
former employee of a state agency we
were always told that when it's a budget
time that you include all federal
dollars if you anticipate them coming so
in fact you don't have to go to fiscals
so you have a total budget picture the
way it should be could you explain why
that you would take it out at this point
or maybe I'm not understanding well okay
so
um
this was explained to me by both the
Chief Financial Officer of of uh the
department and our LBA assistant Mr
Ripple and by moving the money out of
hp1 we just don't reflect the federal
money associated with that money those
General funds we don't we don't
show those federal funds on hb2 even
though that they can come in so it's
it's a state accounting method it's not
seeing none
representative Edwards moves and
representative Earth's second seconds
that the report from division three
on hb1 be accepted
is there any further discussion
thank you chairman Weiler
it's my intention to vote against hb-1
and
you know I sat here this morning and I
listened to the other divisions and I
thought
my goodness
no reductions
in those divisions but when you come to
division three
where we serve the neediest people in
our state
children
the elderly
the lowest income people
there's 50 million dollars back of the
budget reduction
as well as a 22 million dollar
reduction in personnel
cost at the Department of Health and
Human Services
[Music]
all of those as many of you know
also
will cause there to be less federal
dollars available
it's 50 million dollars is General funds
that stands to lose us probably close to
another 50 million
so from services to New Hampshire
citizens
we are reducing our budget by
at least 100 million
when you look at the 22 million dollars
in positions which is 226 positions
some of those positions will be Child
Protection positions positions who work
with the elderly positioned who may work
in our Public Health Labs I mean there's
it's such a vast array of services
provided by that department and it it
really bothered me
that there were few if any reductions in
the other divisions and division three
ended up
several many million dollars worth of
reductions so for that reason I'm voting
no on um House Bill one yeah
Mr chair representative Edwards I I
would just like to respond to that uh
that from the previous budget to the
current budget the budget was increased
18 for the Department
that's unsustainable
um 18 is is is is more than the stake in
sport and what we've done with the next
budget is by the time you take a look at
the previous budget the current budget
and the next budget there's ongoing
steady growth from year to year to year
there's still plenty of headcount for
the number of people who are available
in a very tight job market to be added
and to be hired but we're asking the
department management to do is to grow
but to grow at a reasonable planned and
sustainable rate
that the state can absorb and asking the
taxpayers of the state to pay more
coming out of a pandemic when we have so
many businesses and homes needing to
re-establish themselves I think it we
just need to keep some perspective that
the department is going to grow it's not
any further discussion
a hand up Mr chairman
I see both representative Ober and
representative noidgren representative
Ober
thank you Mr chairman with all due
respect to the previous Finance chair
and my colleague who just spoke
she started by saying the other
if she had been listening this morning
she would have heard that division every
20 million dollars
in addition we added on nearly 30
million of dollars of spending that the
other two divisions could benefit from
I know that none of us want to cut our
divisions every cut in my division hurt
the division members didn't like them I
didn't like them I feel fairly certain
that that was the same with what
happened in division three but we need
to be on record other divisions did make
cuts and other divisions also added
Revenue above and beyond what we had and
Mr chairman just a gentle reminder as
you know at 2 30 I have to go to another
meeting that was previously scheduled
long before this was scheduled and thank
you for letting me speak
thank you representative noidgren
[Music]
thank you Mr chair
and I think I would again call it a
question as representative walner noted
the back of the budget cut of 30 million
the first year and
20 million the second year really
make it clear that we have not done the
work we should have done this is an easy
thing to do I think it also our concern
and I know representative Wallner
representative Rogers shared this
concern uh the department Labs millions
of dollars last year and obviously with
the pandemic and everything else going
on there are probably some reasons for
that but it's my concern that uh what
our budget does
needs to happen and I think the lapsing
and the cuts that we leave up to the
department uh we'll be putting a lot of
people in agencies in Peril and I would
also call attention to the questions I
had on the Family Planning line of fifty
thousand dollars I don't think we have
enough definition of what that does and
I will be voting against toast no one
um I too will be going against this
budget in large part because of what it
takes away from family planning I have
change in funding in combination with
house will tooth change in reality what
will happen
is the number of our health clinics will
not be able to survive and a woman's
right to choose is going to be severely
limited in this state in the Years
um I don't think we have a right to do
that
and while
friend will argue that oh he's not doing
anything to affect that we all know that
it is by having grants to have new
clinics come forward and pick up the
cuddle if you will or whatever they have
this black could be taken out
what to do whatever that's all but um
people are not going to be allowed do we
have enough work and when they need to
if
and that's the first
um I think we should have been more open
about it and transparent I don't think
it should have done the way it was done
um policy the policy should have been
argued in a policy committee who brought
forward that way not done with a sleight
of hand
and but
um that's not the way we do things we've
been
um
[Music]
knows that no state and no federal money
go towards funding any abortion service
what these clinics do with the money we
give them is they do testing for STDs
they do cancer screenings they do
women's health care and for a number of
very poor women in the state it's the
only way they can afford to get that
Healthcare they don't have insurance
they can't pay for it that way and if
these Clinic goes out of business
um where are they going to go I think
yes we'll find out
so for that
reason and others that has been been
talked about by other members are on
this table I can't vote for this budget
thank you very much for your time
um
Mr chairman I respond to that
representative Edwards
so um to just describe the funding
growth in the Family Planning line
at the end of fy19 the state invested
596 000 in Family Planning
at the end of the first year of this
budget
we've accepted the governor's budget
request for Family Planning that's at
eight hundred and twelve thousand so to
go from 596 to 812 is more than a 10 per
year increase in Family Planning there
is absolutely no shortfall in the family
planning in addition to that 812 we put
an extra 50 000 in to stimulate
additional competition to help ensure
that there is no problem with access to
care so so uh we we have
uh there's a hospital too that still
needs to be talked about but in terms of
Family Planning Family Planning is going
to do very very well under this budget
we've protected it we've increased it
more than 10 percent a year since FY 19.
okay I see people keep coming back and
coming back I'd like to cut this short
because we Kevin a lot of repetition did
you want to reply representative Rogers
and you don't have that good a
microphone I can't understand a lot of
so I apologize
um I just want to say that people should
um
should think very carefully about the
words that are said here we all know
that statistics and and budget numbers
can be translated in many ways and I
would just tell people that they should
really check the numbers because in
reality the numbers that are being
thrown about with Family Planning can be
looked at a number of ways and I think
that if we look at the general fund
versus federal funds uh the makeup of
the members and Family Planning are
interpreted by many of us very different
than representative Edwards interprets
them and um I think that language is
important so I would just ask people to
look very carefully before they um make
their assumptions thank you for letting
me result please thank you
no thank you
so Mr chairman because additional
numbers were brought up I think I just
need to address those as well
representative Edwards all right thank
you sir so to keep in
context the eight hundred and twelve
thousand dollars in Family Planning
money that we're investing
um it should be compared a lot of people
are concerned about uh whether or not
uh Planned Parenthood of Northern New
England is going to be able to continue
to to compete for Family Planning
dollars and in the last year
uh Planned Parenthood received probably
about 350 K of the Family Planning money
well what is 350k
last year Planned Parenthood spent six
hundred thousand dollars on lobbying
last year Planned Parenthood spent two
million dollars on marketing
uh last year 32 percent of planned
parenthood's money came from Medicaid
uh in the coming year it's projected
that the federal government will write a
direct appropriation to Planned
Parenthood the tune of eight hundred
thousand dollars a year
so
this little tiny dollop of State monies
for Family Planning
will be used to help Family Planning
counseling and to provide services and I
don't think anyone needs to worry about
the financial
wherewithal of Planned Parenthood
my hand is enough and I have no comment
thank you
okay
seeing no further discussion
a clerk will call a role on acceptance
by the committee of division three's
House Bill one recommendations
thank you Mr chairman
uh representative Ober yes
representative umberger
yes
representative turcotte representative
turkottville chess president of the Burj
yes
president Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative erf
representative Griffin yes
representative Edwards Edwards is yes
representative Doucette yes
representative Lynn yes
representative walner
Representative norgren no representative
bucco no
representative Leachman no
representative hatch
representative Rogers
no
thank you
representative Walsh no
representative Heath
[Music]
he's vote no Rosanna Porter no
thank you and representative Wilder yes
Mr chairman the voters 12 to 90
affirmative
motion is adopted
next representative Edwards will brief
us on the division three changes to hb2
thank you Mr chairman and for the screen
share uh that's it right there so
um Mr chairman I I think we've talked
about the first two hb1 items so I'll
move to hb2 on
um on line
24. uh this deals with the
this deals with the county cap issue
that I discussed earlier because it had
such a significant hp1 effect but this
is the amendment necessary to execute
the
um the uh anticipation of the increased
uh fmap funding uh trying to hold
current and Future
rates of increase for the counties at
two percent
um it also shows the dollar amounts that
we would appropriate from General funds
to the counties to help cover County
Nursing Home expenses
the next item uh the prospective repeal
regarding eligibility of services
[Music]
so we repealed section 25 because the
purpose of of of uh of section 25 had
been a recurring kicking of a of a
of an amendment uh year after year it
had been in there for 10 years and now
because a statute is going into effect
it was no longer needed so we just
simply deleted section 25.
the next one on the repeal of of a
current exemption
um the the this was proposed by the
governor the only thing that we did to
this as an amendment the governor wanted
the repeal authority to or the exemption
Authority rather to to end January 1 of
23 the department wanted June of 23 on a
six to one vote we voted to support the
Department's request to extend it to
June of 23. but that was a
non-controversial
Amendment otherwise
uh the next one uh section 33
was a correction
that was submitted
to pick up an extra hundred thousand
dollars that was available that we just
hadn't accounted for
section
34. this is the amendment uh to the
reproductive Health Facilities Line This
is the the one area that that I'm sure
has stimulated the most contention in
division three it essentially says that
um
Family Planning money
should be given to
those services that are providing the
full range of Family Medical planning
but uh but don't also have
reproductive health facility services
under the same roof if you go to the RSA
and you look at reproductive health
facilities in general but not exactly
but in general a reproductive health
facility is an outpatient abortion
clinic so so when people laymen are
looking at this they can think of it as
just saying we're looking for physical
and financial separation between
clients coming in for Family Planning
services and having abortions provided
under the same roof
this does not affect
in any way the counseling that a woman
can get because the full range of
counseling will be available
abortion is a constitutionally protected
medical service in this country and we
would never I hope we would never
consider Banning a woman from being told
about all of her options
uh regardless of how we may believe of
them they are constitutionally protected
so
um section 35
was a partial acceptance of an Alvarez
and Martinez outside Consulting study we
got this report very late in our process
very late
um uh two weeks later than it was
available to the department and there
were four recommendations that we picked
up that spent some money about 3.3
million dollars but the payoff period
was excellent we got about 10.6 million
from that 3.3 million investment within
the first
biennium so that just was a no-brainer
uh we we we accepted that section with
an amendment
then section 37
was a proposal in the governor's budget
to invest 1.5 million at senior citizen
centers to help them purchase
barriers and other infrastructure to
help with the covid protection and the
issue we had with this one the reason
that we deleted it
was although we supported the concept
and the need entirely there's about 800
different organizations in the state
that would qualify as a Senior Citizen
Center so and there was nothing in the
section that dealt with who was eligible
who was not and how the bids would go
and with a little tiny amount of 1.5
million it would have been smarter for
the state to just write two thousand
dollars checks to each Senior Citizen
Center but the department can't do that
they can only give money to somebody
that they have a legit government
contract with so because the overhead
expenses were take up such a huge
portion of the 1.5 we just simply
deleted it
um
uh number 38 we discussed earlier this
was
um
uh two hundred thousand dollars
initially that was in hb2 for an ongoing
operation an ongoing expense so we moved
it out of hb2 into hb1 and when we moved
it we discovered six hundred thousand
dollars of federal funds that are is
attached to it so that's 600 000 also
got added back to the budget from the
federal line uh when we moved the 200
000 in hb1
um item 39 I would say would be one of
the two greatest areas of agreement that
we had
um a uh section 39 was a proposal in the
governor's budget to go ahead and build
a new forensic Mental Health Hospital on
the grounds of near the New Hampshire
hospital and uh it had language in there
essentially taking General funds and and
in lieu of capital funds uh it went from
a 25 bed facility which was uh approved
in the previous biennium to 60 beds with
really no explanation of the difference
between the two so so what we did here
was we deleted section 39
um from the version we're going to send
over the Senate and the division three
is going to have a joint hearing with
public works and with HHS on April 12th
so that we can dig deeper into this
issue
and then from there we intend to provide
notes over to the senate for their
consideration we just didn't have time
to hear everything that needed to be
heard on that
and then the the last one
um those okay those were all the changes
to
um
to to HP to the sections that we we
inherited then we started a bunch of new
ones that are really the um the first
one is around the Medicaid management
information system we moved that from
hb1 over to hb2 I've talked about that
so this is a new line item amendment
um we
I'm having trouble remembering the child
I think we added funds it's my memory
but I should double check
s
okay
um
so
this amendment was an authorization to
use TANF money which is federal money
that may be available if the
commissioner were to determine that we
have a employment related wait list for
child care services and so so this was
us trying to help solve a weightless
problem for child care services related
to employment and to use federal funds
to help make up the shortfall
so
um the next one uh relative to state of
emergency declaration this is one that
we had some controversy in the in the
committee
um and and what this basically does is
it allows the governor to declare a
state of emergency
um and to begin
meeting his executive obligations under
a state of emergency but it calls in a
need to get the legislature involved in
extending the state of emergency beyond
the first 21 days and so if the
legislature is deemed to be able to meet
with a quorum then the legislature needs
to meet in order to extend the state of
emergency but if we cannot get a quorum
from the legislature then the governor
can continue to extend on 21 day
increments so that's that's an end of
the um
that that would bring the legislature
back into being a co-equal branch with
from there down there's a series of
amendments related to closure of the
sununu center you know transferring
property making sure that people are
retained everyone who has a job at the
sununu center uh will is expected to be
canceled and helped with the retraining
and re-classification process so that
they can continue
as state employees and then it transfers
the property over to administrative
services without prejudice meaning
there's different opinions on how that
land could be repurposed but but our
committee was silent on what we intend
the land to be used for
and with that sir I'll take any
okay representative nordgren for a
question
no my hand is adopt sorry
okay no question no
represent leishman for a question
thank you Mr chairman so if we could go
back to section
34 commission for the chair
of division three so I appreciate you
saying that a woman's right to choose is
constitutionally protected but as I read
the amendment
it would appear to be that it just makes
it a lot more difficult for that
woman to
is
so as it stands now the majority of the
Family Planning clinics
that receives State money do not provide
abortion services
I I don't know if many people know that
but the majority do not and so
um this is not a Prohibition on the
client the woman receiving counseling
on abortion services to include
locations to include help with the
referral
to to include the whole
mail you of options that she has
all it does is it says that when she's
walking down the hallway to the Family
Planning counselor she's not walking by
abortion procedure rooms
there there will be a physical and
financial separation between the
counseling and the abortion provision
abortion uh in in that setting is is
very much like a self-referral
federal law has for decades recognized
the anti-kickback issues around
uh Physicians and other providers being
able to refer to their own own services
and have forced providers to to be at
arm's length when there's a perception
that there could be a financial
inducement to weigh on one type of
referral or over another so so this is
um a a rule that has been taken through
courts and has been validated as
something that the state can can
establish
representative nordgren did you have
your hand up
upset with the characterization of
Representative Edwards in what the
Family Planning organizations do and
that they would make Kickback money I
mean that just totally wrong and
misstated and I can't believe people
believe that but I also wanted to
comment on the emergency order uh issue
um I think uh that's something that
obviously the chair of Finance told us
was because he needed votes and
um this was inserted at the last minute
so that's a frustration
um but I would also
um
thank representative Weiler and
representative wellner in their
great collaboration in in putting
together all the Amendments we needed to
move forward with the sununu center
um and I think that's something we did
as a group and that was well done thank
you
representative Porter for comment or a
question
thank you Mr chair and I I would like to
ask representative Edwards
um many of the abortions that are
performed what's called medical
abortions which a doctor prescribes a
pill that the patient takes at home
um
how will that
will the Family Planning clinics need to
have a special building and me and staff
it so that people can go in and talk to
their doctor and get a prescription
I'm I'm missing some of the words and
what you're saying and I'm I'm I'm I'm
concerned that they're critical words in
your question I want me to ask it again
representative
yes please because for some reason the
there's a muffle in in a few of those
words
let me check my uh volume is that better
I I hope so let's let's try it again so
my question is that many abortions that
have performed are what is called
medical abortions where a doctor a
physician prescribes a pill that a
patient takes at home right um
under the provisions of this amendment
would a
a family planning Clinic have to have a
separate building and staff a separate
building to give prescriptions to their
patients for a medical abortion
hmm that's a really great question it's
the first time I've heard the question
uh in hundreds of emails and many hours
of testimony that's the first time I've
heard that question and I'll just State
uh frankly that I I don't know
um and uh
the the the term reproductive health
facility is defined in RSA 130 colon 37
I would need to go back over to that to
to figure out whether or not the ability
to prescribe
that that
but after oh he wants the right word uh
the ability to prescribe that particular
pill to terminate a pregnancy I don't
know if that's defined currently as an
abortion or as a contraceptive and I
know that there's been court cases on
both sides of that and I I just I just
can't tell you that I know the answer
no I don't
say no further questions
representative Edwards moves and
representative Earth seconds that
division threes changes to hb2 be
accepted by the finance committee
clerical column is there any further
discussion representative Wallner
thank you Mr chairman
um I am going to vote against Hospital
too but before I do I just want to say
thank you to um all the members of our
division I think everyone here today and
watching
out there in Zoom land
um we can tell
how difficult the work of division three
is
so I just want to thank all of the
members of the division for the hard
work that we've done the LBA staff has
been incredible they've been there with
us through the whole thing and they
deserve a lot of a lot of praise and a
lot of thanks
I don't think we could have done this
without Zoom
at the beginning I never would have
thought we could have gotten through it
but we did and
um thank goodness for technology it
actually ended up working pretty well
most of the time
and I wanted to say a special thanks to
the people at the Department of Health
and Human Services who were there with
us
throughout these sessions they've been
there every day Karen rounds and her
team they were incredible they were
really helpful and I really appreciate
all the all the help they gave our
division
thank you thank you representative
Rogers
thank you Mr chairman I hope that my
sound is a little better now
um I want to say that I again have to
vote against House Bill 2 for a similar
reason I think that it was clear
um when we talked about House Bill one
that certain Representatives want to use
this budget to defund
um certain places such as planned
parenthood
um and the amendment to this which
requires a separate facility
um
for certain clinics to do abortions in
an abortion Services is an impossible
standard to meet
um the clinics that exist in this state
with their facilities are not wealthy
they would need to construct or purchase
separate buildings from where they are
now which is probably impossible for
most of them which will in reality
require that they either close or they
no longer perform services or no longer
um accept or ask for Grants from the
state
um and we lose their services which I
think would be disastrous for the State
of New Hampshire whether someone is
pro-life or pro-choice
um I still think that we need to have
these available
um not everybody's going to take
um
and use these services but I think they
should be there and as I said I don't
think we should be deciding this policy
in the finance committee we often say we
don't do policy but I guess we do and I
guess we now do it more than we ever
have in the past
um as I said you can argue that oh they
can still exist but the reality is far
different than that and we can do double
speak we can do 1984 language
Corrections and and say anything we want
but if we get down to the truth of the
matter then I think I'll see what's
going on so I um I can't vote for this
in addition as others have mentioned I
can't support the total
um
dismantling of the health and human
services department yes there might be 3
000 employees it's a large Department
some would even say too large and we
maybe should split it into separate
departments but that doesn't mean we
should make them work so that they can't
perform the duties we've given them to
form we've been through a pandemic where
there's been hiring freezes and they
haven't been allowed to fill vacancies
we've shifted things on them and now
we're just telling them to do more with
less and that might be popular rhetoric
to ask people to do but then when we
come back in two years and they've been
able to do even less than they've been
able to do during a pandemic with
programs other than dealing with the
disease that's put us all here are we
going to cut them again I hope not I
hope then we'll maybe listen
um so I I thank you Mr chairman for all
the work that many of us have put in
um but I hope that maybe we'll stop the
rhetoric someday and actually get down
business thank you so much
representative nordgren did you leave
your hand up or is this something new I
did put it up this up this time thank
as Mary Jane said I would compliment the
staff at the department they were with
us the whole way they met with us well
we needed to figure things out and and
obviously Kevin Ripple and the staff at
LBA have been there all along the way
and I'm sure they had a long weekend
helping organize us
um I guess it's disturbing to me having
been here probably way too long that the
Health Human Services budget seemed to
have been put together by the right wing
of the Republican party and I can't
remember a time in my history here where
that's been so blatantly announced to
everybody
um
so I will be voting against this budget
thank you
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chairman I I I I consider uh the term
right-wing uh Republican to be a
disparaging term but but I'll move on
from that because what I really want to
do is I I want to uh uh acknowledge and
thank as a being new to finance and
being new as a chair how much I
appreciated uh representative nordgren
as the previous chair stepping in and
helping me and giving me advice and then
representative Wallen throughout the
whole time has been a a great mentor and
willing to talk with me I really
appreciate that and uh and I've I've
appreciated and enjoyed representative
Rogers participation so everyone I think
on the committee uh worked hard and we
tried to find where we could Agree to
Agree and obviously we did find those
places where we can't agree but Mr
Ripple and the staff has been great the
Department's been great I
I I think we're giving the department a
good budget they can grow they can grow
but they just need to grow a little bit
more responsibly than what had been
anticipated
thank you
is your hand still up representative
no okay
thank you okay we're ready for the
question the clerk will call a roll on
the acceptance of hb2 changes by
division three
thank you Mr chairman representative
Ober
[Music]
I believe she's out represent umberger
yes
representative turcott
representative turcott yes
representative yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative erf
representative Griffin
representative Edwards
yes
representative Doucette yes
representative Lynn yes
[Music]
uh Representative walner no
no
Representative leishman no
representative hatch no
Rosanna Rogers no
representative walls no
representative Porter no
representative Wilder
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 11 to 9 in the
affirmative motion is adopted we have
some more important things to do you all
have the uh full committee there's some
amendments
I hope you can find that peace the first
page is the latest
estimates of unrestricted Revenue this
was an update
from representative major
it's another 43 million but it was too
late by the time we got it to start down
start working on it all over again but
any good suggestions can go to the
Senate and we can
know that they'll have that and probably
some more money
so
I'll entertain a motion to adopt the
seconds to adopt the estimates of
unrestricted Revenue
you're muted
I'm fine could you could it be scrolled
there's a couple of pages to it okay all
okay
seeing none are you ready for the
question
clerk will call a role on adopting the
representative Ober
right here there was an umberger
yes
representative turcotte
yes version of The Verge yes
president Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative erf
representative Griffin yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Doucette yes
representative Lynn yes
I'm sorry I was that again yes oh thank
you
yes
leishman yes
representative hatch yes
representative Rogers yes
representative walls yes
representative Heath
representative Porter yes representative
Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 20 to zip in
favor of the ocean
thank you motion is adopted
next move on to amendments to hb2
representative turcotte
moves
the adoption of
amendment number one zero
remember the amendment of one zero three
four h representative Doucet seconds
[Music]
oh
that's the next one
okay
all right
any further discussion our hand up Sir
representative Edwards all right uh I I
intend to vote for this amendment
the family medical leave is a is a great
policy and I and I'm sure that it's
operating your great concept uh but this
is an outstanding kind of Bill that
really ought to go through a full policy
here and uh have a fiscal note attached
to it so that we can we can see what's
really uh what what will happen if we
pass it but I'll be I'll be supporting
uh yes thank you Mr chairman I would
like to speak in uh
in favor of this um I I find it uh the
fmli uh
the best places not for it to be in
House Bill 2 uh in my opinion it is not
great policy to begin with
um extend plans like this already exist
in the private market and those plans
are extremely expensive
um I'm not for putting fmli
uh cost of it on the taxpayers as this
currently would do
um
and uh
I think that's good for now thank you
thank you I couldn't tell if
representative Duce said in his hand
though
no I don't have my hand up thank you
see no further discussion the clerk will
call the roll on Amendment
one zero three four
right Mr chairman uh who uh moved that
motion
representative turcotte representative
Doucette seconded
okay you said okay very good
all right representative Ober is not
here
there's an umberger
yes
representative turcotte yes
representative with reservations yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative erf
thank you
representative Edwards yes
[Music]
representative Doucet yes
representative Lynn yes
representative Waldner yes
yes
representative Rogers yes
those are walls yes
representative Heath
representative uh Porter yes
and representative Wilder yes
Mr chairman the vote is 20 to nothing in
the affirmative motion is adopted
next we have a reduction in the business
profits tax this was requested at the
last minute by the Ways and Means
Committee representative Ober put her
name on it but uh because the the
revenue picture
Ways and Means didn't think we could
afford to go from 7.7 to 7.5 so they
made it from 7.7 to 7.6 and that's a
changed in in what we had done
originally so
this is a tax reduction but not to the
same extent that it was before I'll
entertain a motion anybody want to make
the motion to adopt Amendment
1031h it works almost
moved and who was the second
representative Burge any further
discussion on this
seeing none the clerk will call a role
on the motion to adopt amendment number
1031 to hb2
B2
representative bumberger yes
[Music]
representative charcoal
yes
there's no Petri votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Earth
representative Griffin
yes
representative Lynn yes
representative Waldner no
Representative norbury no
representative bucco no
representative Leachman no
representative hatch no
representative Rogers no
walls no
representative Porter no
representative Wilder yes
Mr chairman the vote is 11-9 in the
affirmative
and the motion is adopted
lastly we'll have representative Edwards
introduce Amendment
1026h yes sir thank you this is uh an
issue that came to me uh really after we
had adjourned our last division three
hearing and um what what the situation
is is that
um as the department is integrating a
number of services one of the
Cornerstone foundational elements of the
overall infrastructure uh is something
referred to uh as a closed loop referral
system it's essentially a way uh the
closed loop part of it means regardless
of where you are in the state as you're
being referred from one place to another
this I.T system provides enable enabling
technology to track those referrals uh
it's intended to enable improved
coordination between providers and and
community-based non-health care
providers others that provide things
like certain the social determinants of
Health Food security housing security
and the like so so this issue is really
one of about whether or not
um it's been reviewed adequately from a
privacy perspective because anyone who
touches any uh Health Care t i t system
in the state will potentially end up in
this database under a master client
index to where all referrals can be
tracked that's the point of it
um the the funding for this came from a
Federal grant seven hundred thousand
dollars
directly to the department
when it came time for the executive
Council to approve this sole source
contract it was put on their agenda as
informational only so the executive
Council didn't even really look at it
and so what this amendment is is doing
is saying uh go ahead Department spend
the 700 000 that you got from the
federal funds but before you start to
spend more than that
you you need to subject this system to a
privacy review by the legislature and it
specifically calls out the House and
Senate standing committees over help and
Human Services and also the Health and
Human Services oversight committee I've
spoken with the chairman of house hhsea
who is also the chairman of the house
oversight and he agrees that this
privacy issue based on other privacy
issues that the committee has seen this
term is something that we really need to
look chat in light of uh our recently
minted constitutional protection of
privacy and
a somewhat
nonchalant attitude about the right of
data ownership by the person
so so this amendment attempts to
establish a a privacy review before more
money is spent
foreign
Edward where did this amendment come
from
uh I I drafted it
um like 12 hours after our last
adjournment I literally did not know
this was an issue until after we
finished our last session so I worked
with Mr Ripple on an OLS on the language
and so it's
it's from OLS
so this is an amendment that's coming to
us
um and I don't remember I mean I
remember
having discussion I didn't remember us
talking about this in division
about
um
closing the uh not allowing them to
expand
I know for us talking about that in
division is that right
it's really kind of hard for me to hear
you because I have tinnitus and I'm
sorry no it's it's all right I I think
what you're asking me is did we talk
about this in division no we didn't
because I literally didn't know about it
until Vision meetings had been done
which is why I'm bringing it to the full
committee and not having done our work
um at this point I'm I'm going to vote
no on this uh mainly because I don't
really have enough information and I
don't know what I really don't know what
the um consequences of this particular
Amendment will be that had not had the
opportunity to talk with the Department
oh I think it was representative Edwards
moved
yes thank you sorry I don't think you
can see my hand up when you're standing
there in that important podium
um behind right behind where the hand
goes up there's something on your wall
that sometimes I look and I can't tell
whether it's the hand or that thing on
the wall sorry
maybe I should move my chair
um I would just like represent Edwards
to
in more detail the role of the House and
Senate I guess it's a little vague to me
and I share the concerns that
representative Wallner has that we
really don't
understand what this means because we
just saw it on a piece of paper so maybe
representative Edwards could explain
more what the role of the House and
uh thank you for the question I I would
describe the role as uh the people's
representative the people voted 81 82
percent just a couple of years ago to
establish a right to privacy in the New
Hampshire Constitution and this I.T
system is
um
[Music]
particularly assertive at reaching out
and in an interconnected Network kind of
way
being able to pull
records on individuals from
widely disparate Health Systems and
community-based services systems so that
so that so that care coordinators can
see in one snapshot all of the services
that are touching uh each client that's
in the database and so there are things
such as uh has the client
provided consent
to the extent to which data will be
pulled together from a wide range of
systems
has the client uh given permission for
his or her information to be shared by
anyone who happens to be in the network
as has the client uh been able to say
these groups can use my information but
these groups cannot
can the client ask at a subsequent date
for the system to delete and forget
those things that can be deleted or
forgotten medical information can't be
deleted but other things such as
Community contacts uh at a at a food
pantry or or clothing distribution site
those kinds of things gotten so so
there's an entire
client privacy set of issues here
that no one other than the department
has looked at and this particular system
the closed loop referral system is
really
um seems to be like the central
connecting Hub within the entire network
to make sure that all of the records
across the community-based providers can
be integrated to create a single
snapshot of all of those contact points
with the community as such it's got a
tremendous amount of personal
information in it a lot of personal
health information
and so uh so it should be subject to
review by the people's body to make sure
that the Privacy rights of the people
are being protected
and I don't think
most of us are even aware that this was
existing with all this access to our
information you had further
representative Wallner
norgren so so
can you
tell me again what would the Senate and
House
plan to do would they have hearings
would they create a bill would they have
legislation next session I guess I don't
understand your plans or how the House
and Senate would be involved
well well specifically it calls out the
Health and Human Services foresight
committee as an example and the chairman
of the Health and Human Services
oversight committee is
um
working with the Department to add this
topic to the agenda that's set in April
and so we will uh I'm on that committee
and the other person that's on the
committee
um a representative saloway the three of
us have talked and said that this is a
pretty significant issue to be moving
so rapidly without oversight of anyone
in the legislature and when the
executive Council had an opportunity to
look at it they simply had an
information piece on it so so might
there be a bill or something come out of
it uh they're they're very well maybe
um but I I can't prejudge the
information the department May in fact
have outstanding you know industry
standard consent forms and and
information about how their information
is getting used and how uh if any if if
the client has any ability to be
forgotten by the network it all of that
could be perfect and it would come
across very quickly in an oversight
committee and the issue would be dropped
I think but we don't know what we don't
know yet we just know that it's big
representative Rogers and then
representative Lynn
yes I just have a question
um actually have you talked to the
department and did they have any input
into this at all
no the department did not talk to me as
the chairman of division three very
interested in I.T issues very much
involved with them on the mmis issue the
ADT issue this issue was not brought to
me and it it and and it had gone largely
it would have gone completely unaware to
me had it not been told to me by a
concerned citizen of privacy advocate so
so because of the shortness of time
getting the amendment and all no the
Department's not been consulted but they
would be consulted if if HHS oversight
adds them to the agenda in April
and if I could do a follow-up
yes follow-up what what would it be
better to bring this to the Senate so
that they would have the time to consult
with the department and um and take a
little more time looking at it
well uh there's a couple of different
ways of getting into the Senate as you
know I mean we could pass it in the
Senate will see it because it's the
house position at that point
um or
um uh it could be administratively
handed and coordinated with them I I
don't know which way would be preferable
in this situation I'm advocating that we
go ahead and add it hb2 to be clear that
the uh to do our best to make sure the
Senate sees it because the Privacy
aspect of this is potentially enormous
and it's just really worth checking on
I'm just concerned representative
because you're the only one that's had
time to look at this the division hasn't
the department hasn't
um if it goes to the Senate as a
suggested Amendment it gives time for
the Senate to look at it more in depth
without us putting in we don't know what
our position is right now we know what
your position is but none of the rest of
us have had a chance to really give it
the time it deserves so that's why I
guess I would prefer
um that you bring it to the Senate and
suggest that they add it in there when
they've had time to look at it and not
ask us to take a position on something
that we know a little about thank you
very much
representative it's a very fair comment
and for completeness representative erf
has also looked at this at an extent
equal to my own
representative Lynn yeah you know I
guess I just have a question I I'm
my understanding I mean from from you
know seeing doctors that I've seen is
that they that this kind of thing is
pretty standard in other words I I think
that the my understanding is that you
know I've that
I I have seen a number of doctors for
different things and that all of them
have all of the information now uh you
know because it's computerized and and
actually I think that's pretty much a
good thing um I understand your private
privacy concerns you raise
um but I guess what I'm wondering is
I'm not quite sure why we're singling
out this particular situation
um I mean maybe there should I'm not
necessarily saying I'm opposed to having
a privacy inquiry into these kind of
things but I'm not quite sure why it
would be limited
to this because as I say my
understanding is and I think you know as
to the extent that I
that I know this I think that it's
pretty standard for this kind of stuff
to be to be done and I and generally
there are these consent forms that you
know I'm I'm sure I've signed a million
of these consent forms and I've never
really paid I haven't really read very
closely because
frankly I didn't care all that much
but that's that's really my question is
this do we know that this isn't really
very widespread Beyond this one contract
so thank you for the question and
um the closed loop referral system is
essentially intended to be a a a a a hub
that uh with in conjunction with the
master client index which is a unique
identifier for every individual that
touches the system that Master client
index and the interconnection that's
planned for what they refer to as the
network
can extend to every medical information
system in the state in every community
based service in the state so if a a
community-based service is providing
transition housing or other housing
assistance or dealing with the food
insecurity issue or coordinating
Transportation or the child advocate has
been called out to the site or law
enforcement has gotten there this is
this is not just your doctor taking your
medical information and on that consent
form it says I would like to be able to
share this medical information with
other people who I will involve in your
health care
on the and so so when you are signing
that consent form you are allowing that
provider to share but the sharing is
specifically defined in the typical
consent form to taking care of your
Health Care
consistent with the what the provider is
doing for you so it's an arrangement
between doctors this is totally
different this is a this is a network
that any system that touches any service
that you get from the state or the
government can interconnect so there is
a One-Stop shop for the entire array of
everything about you where you've
touched
one of the services okay so it's it's
it's 10 to 100 times the magnitude of of
is
do you is there is there some kind of a
consent
form or we just don't know I I haven't
reviewed it I've been told that it says
that you consent to share your
information within the network and then
the question is is Network defined in a
way in which you can reasonably
understand the comprehensive nature of
all of the data that's being compiled
and integrated so you could go yeah
Network that sounds good but then you
don't know what's in the network is law
enforcement in the network is the food
pantry in the network is is the domestic
violence program in the network
everything about you
can be in that Network
it seems okay and that's why we want to
look into it to make sure that you're
protected that you know what you're
consenting to
thank you thank you appreciate it all
right so next I have representative erft
and representative walner then
so
it even goes beyond what
representative Edwards was referring to
it's not only state and government
it's Meals on Wheels it's
the idn it's your marriage counselor
it's anybody
and as far as the
what we've talked about here right now I
would think the questions that we have
here
would give us pause
that the department did not come to us
to ask us to implement a new program
which is what this is
as representative Edwards says not even
the executive Council was able to take a
vote on this
as far as the consent goes
currently
it's basically a lot of gibberish the
kind of same sort of thing you get when
you go and get a download a free app
from
your phone store
and you agree
furthermore you got to imagine that many
people
in this situation are and not a great
place mentally
looking for food or they're looking for
counseling or whatever their client just
to do is
what you do when you get a free app
agree it's a one-time agreement that
cannot be rescinded that lasts in
perpetuity
and basically anybody in the quote
Network
and that includes not just government
officials but these private entities as
well have access to your data so it's
pretty clear
when I heard about this I was stunned
that's a program like this sole source
contract not put out to bid
the next phase that's been requested is
again sole source contract
not put out to bid
a system like this with the same
company
was put into I believe North Carolina
had a eight million dollar price tag as
I recall
we're doing the same thing apparently
Pennsylvania also looked at this
they on the other hand put it out to bid
and their contract came back at two
million dollars
so there seemed to be quite a few
questions around this the kinds of
things that I think the legislature is
intended to
look at and come up with the proper
legislative approach
conjunction with the governor to
implementing thank you Mr chairman thank
you
intent of this amendment included in any
um legislation that's presently before
one of the Committees in the house
it seems like the Health and Human
uh as as I understand the issue that
they've dealt with it was an issue of
opt-in and opt out of a particular
information system and this is and and
and based on the input that they got
from the department and on that I.T
system that there is a concern amongst
many on in that committee that the
department
does not have a due respect for an
individual's privacy right and to
control their personal data and and so
and that instance that you're referring
to was just one system this closed-loop
system is going to interconnect with the
everything in the department and Beyond
as representative or said so it's it's
it's it's something very different than
what HHS looked at in you say 601 I'll
believe it
so wouldn't it be better at this point
for
the Health and Human Service committee
since they've already started looking at
this I mean it might be just one
contract but they're already looking at
this wouldn't it be better for them to
continue their work in this area I mean
it sounds like this is an issue that
needs
um to have a public hearing needs to
gather a lot more information than what
we're going to be able to get here
between the 15 of us today right 20 of
us so so what this amendment does is it
basically Flags the issue and requires
that it go before a House and Senate
standing committee over HHS and to the
HHS oversight foreign except that what
it does is it prohibits the department
um from expanding any services at this
point so I mean it does both but right
it does it also does uh prohibit that
they get to spend the whole 700 000 that
they were given on a direct
appropriation from the federal
government but to expand beyond that
we need to take a look at it that's
I think my concern is we're in the 11th
inning of our action on a budget bill
that's before us this obviously
needs a lot more
discussion a lot a lot more research and
a lot more information provided to those
of us that need to vote on someone
so I would
respectfully asked and the unfairest of
me not to be embanked about something
but
um maybe it would be prudent for us to
withdraw this amendment for right now I
don't understand why we urgently need to
address this now
there's going to be tons of opportunity
in the very near future to address this
appropriately and properly but maybe we
should consider doing that just that so
I would ask respectfully if maybe this
amendment could be withdrawn
and we can go forward forward with the
business of the day thank you Mr chair
anyone else
representative nordgren have you got
your hand up
I'll come to you next
with all due respect
the last few
points are making the point
this initial contract
was entered into without any oversight
they're currently looking to and enter
into an 8.1 million dollar contract
without any further oversight
these are federal dollars coming from
the federal government
can we as legislators should be able to
have some input into what kind of
programs are being implemented in the
state of New Hampshire
so it is actually imperative
that we implement this now it's not that
we're taking anything away from anybody
we're putting in place something to do
exactly what has been pointed out here
the legislature should be involved and
all this is doing is saying exactly that
and the Senate would like us to take a
position just as they'd like us to take
a position on a variety of things so
they know what the house position is
when things get to them you're
absolutely right when it gets to the
Senate they'll definitely look at it
they may take it out
but they also may say you know we need
to look into this more deeply and we
need to allow the legislative process to
work the way the legislative process is
intended to work
thank you Mr chairman
representative noidgren uh I didn't have
representative Lynn yeah you know as
I've as I've looked at this language
though I I guess I I'm I'm sort of
persuaded by one of the comments that
was made earlier uh
um it says that though that the there
should be no further expansion of this
of the contract
um in the amount of 700 000 but then
when you read the next sentence
the closed loop referral system shall
not be made available to or or
accessible by members of the general
public or the department
prior to the enactment of legislation so
what if the situation is that yes
they've entered into this 700 000
contract but they've only spent a
hundred thousand dollars of it and there
are other people who would want to take
advantage of it under the contract can
they do it or not I see a sort of
section one would say where the first
sentence which seem to say well maybe
they can but the second sentence would
seem to say no
um that they that they can't that that
because that would be a further that
would be an expansion that would be uh
uh
shall be made no the the closed loop
referral system shall not be made
available to or accessible so if I'm if
I'm the person that's going to get
that would be would would be taking
advantage of the contract because it
hasn't been fully expended but I'm not I
don't take advantage of it you know
before this law is enacted can
can I can the department offer that to
me if it's within the seven hundred
thousand
thank you for the question I I sit here
thinking to myself if only I could find
a lawyer to ask about that uh but uh
but uh I'm not a lawyer uh this got
drafted by OLS at my uh request and I
had some conditions I was trying to meet
my primary uh motivator is
there's a tremendous amount of power and
information and we're given up
the way this is the trajectory of this
we're given up a tremendous amount of
insight into our personal lives with
this interconnection as I understand the
interconnection and and there has not
been any legislative oversight of the
closed-loop referral system and how it's
going to interconnect and Network
and so to your your specific question I
I don't have an answer for you I I I'd
kind of like to get it into hb2 so that
the Senate sees it so the Senate talks
about it so so I could take your
question to them and and get a refined
and resolved but I I I'm a I'm a privacy
Advocate and I just do not like that
we're going willy nilly down a very fast
slope towards the end of personal
privacy by having the the one system
connect the entire network together on
your master client index I just we need
to be very careful we have a duty to
bye
well what we're doing here today really
concerns me because I I do believe that
this issue has been before one of our
policy committees
and that
um they have had a robust discussion of
this
and they have a report coming out and
actually The Minority Report asked for
an amendment that is very similar
to what we are seeing before us now and
I think we're trying to do a in run
around one of our policy committees and
I think that Finance should not be doing
that and
um I will certainly be voting no on this
amendment
any further discussion I I just would
want to remind uh representative Wallner
that this has been coordinated with the
chairman of HHS and what the vice chair
of HHS and with representative saloway
from HHS and they all agree that this
has not been the subject of one of their
current bills but it's it but it's the
same general topic uh and I respect your
clerk will call the roll on the motion
to adopt
[Music]
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
vonberger
yes
representative
uh yes
representative yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative URF
representative Griffin yes
yes representative Edwards yes
representative sat yes
representative Lynn no
yay
representative walner
no
Representative norgren no
representative Buco no
Representative leishman no
version of hatch no
representative Rogers no
representative Walsh no
representative Porter no
representative Weiler yes
uh Mr chairman we have a 10 10 tie
nice okay in the event of a tie the
legislative budget assistant is there
any further action to come before the
committee today
no we just um thank you for your work
today we would just ask for the ability
to make Technical and mechanical changes
to reflect the intent of the votes today
and then what we will do is work with
OLS to put together House Bill one and
two an official Amendment form so that
the committee can take a vote on those
at a later date are are the members all
uh and with the legislative budget
assistant having appreciated having
Tuesday to do all your final work
sure whatever works for the committee
will be working whatever you need us to
do we'll make sure that it's done
then what I will do is I will recess
this hearing until Wednesday
at nine if that works for everybody
those of you that have to take two and
three hour drives
don't have to do one tomorrow
Mr chairman
wait wait wait I'm listening to
representative umberger representative
emberger
I think that's an excellent suggestion
who else was calling was that
representative Rogers yes
um will we be done by noon on Wednesday
I have an appointment in the afternoon
so I was just checking
will we be done by noon on Wednesday
I don't think there's all that much to
do if we don't have all that much
discussion
so I would hope we would be done by noon
okay thank you
Representatives uh Edwards uh yes sir
could you remind me did we decide that
HB 600 should go on the consent calendar
is all right
no there wasn't a motion on the floor
I'm not ready for that yet okay
did anybody have any objection to House
Bill 600 which we passed today being on
the consent calendar I believe we had a
without without objection uh it's going
on the consent calendar thank you
sorry uh I moved that uh we provide or
give the LBA permission to make any
technical Corrections that are necessary
in the uh completing of hb1 and hb2
did the LBA understand the motion yes
okay and a motion in a second
any further discussion on the motion
seeing none you ready for the question
yes representative turcott yes
representative Burge yes
representative Peter votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative erf
version of Griffin yes
representative Edwards
representative Doucet yes
representative Lynn yes
representative norgren yes
president Buco yes
president Leachman
representative hatch
representative Rogers yes
representative Walsh yes
representative Heath
representative Porter yes
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman of Voters 20-0
okay
hope being 20-0 we have completed our
work we will be back on Wednesday at
nine and hopefully we will have a short
day as we review all the work that LBA
has done and we're very grateful to them
and I hope they don't have to work too
hard tomorrow to get everything done
and we'll be back on Wednesday morning
to uh do the final touches
and be ready to present the following
Monday it will be mainly the committee
uh
division chairs that will be doing the
the
presentation to the Full House it'll
probably be a lot of questions many of
the rest of you are interested in in
coming and observing what the questions
will be you're welcome
um at this point
we may be doing it here in the chamber
I'm not sure at this point we'll have to
be talking to the the leadership but my
presumption would be that we likely
would have this session in here on
next Monday the 5th when we present to
the Full House
and there may be a number of people that
want to attend in person so
we'll be ready to
speak to them as well
so I thank you all for all the
dedication and work this is the toughest
committee to be on in the house during
budget period we'll have a little bit of
rest next year maybe we won't be quite
so busy but
we'll have made up for it so I thank you
all for your attendance and your good
comments and your questions because
that's the way it works so
they're all working together
as always we may have disagreements but
we'll do our best to find common ground
thank you all for attending
[Music]